hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel this video is based on
node.js full cores we will begin with
full course video by understanding what
exactly node.js is next we will go
through the installation process of
node.js and make the computer ready for
node.js development next we will have an
in-depth understanding of node.js
architecture and some of its popular
modules next we will see how to interact
with apis using the express framework
based on node.js then we will see how to
use node.js in web applications and api
services then we will look into the web
authentication using json web tokens
then we will look into using node.js
with database systems like mysql and
mongodb and at the end we will look into
node.js interview questions and answers
that summarize every important node.js
concept and serve as a perfect
preparation resource for node.js
interviews
by the end of this video i can assure
you that you will have a proper
understanding of node.js concepts and
you will also be able to use this
framework in a web development
applications
so let's start with an exciting video on
node.js before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon and never miss an update
from simply learn welcome to this video
by simply learn in today's session we're
going to learn all about node.js so
without further ado let's begin and look
at what's in store for us first up we'll
understand what exactly node.js is then
we'll understand the necessity of
node.js then we learn about some of the
parts of node.js node.js express
framework node.js use cases and finally
we'll look at some of the industry
trends so what exactly is node.js now
consider a scenario where a user
interacts with the web application the
user only interacts with the front end
of the application but there's a lot of
work that goes behind the scenes
now in a web application there's a front
end a server and a database the
front-end is developed using javascript
and frameworks like angular and react
while the server is built on java php or
node.js and the backend database that
stores the data usually consists of
mysql or mongodb so node.js is an open
source cross-platform javascript runtime
environment for running server-side
applications it is used to develop
io-intensive web applications like video
streaming sites single-page applications
online chatting applications and other
web applications it is used by large
established companies and newly minted
startups node.js was developed by ryan
dal in 2009 and at the same time of this
session its latest version is v13.3.0
now that we know what node.js is let's
go ahead and look at why it was so
prevalent in the field of web
development here are a few points first
up node.js is extremely fast being built
on google chrome's v8 javascript engine
its library is extremely fast in code
execution note package manager has
around 50 000 bundles for developers so
whatever functionality is required for
an application can be easily imported
from npm all apis of node.js library are
asynchronous that is non-blocking it
means a node.js based server never waits
for an api to return data node.js
dramatically reduces the processing time
while uploading video and audio files it
is also an open source platform and is
easy for beginners for web development
the above reasons more than justify the
popularity of node.js platform and why
it is being adopted by large number of
organizations and businesses today so
now moving on let's familiarize
ourselves with the parts of node.js
node.js consists of several components
now let's look at them one by one first
up we have modules now modules are like
javascript libraries which are used in a
node.js application to include a set of
functions now we can use require
function with the parenthesis to include
a module in a node.js application
node.js application has many modules to
provide basic functionality needed for a
web application some of them could be
http util fs url query string stream and
zlip next up we have console the console
module provides a simple debugging
console that is similar to the
javascript console mechanism provided by
web browsers now the console can print
messages to std out that prints standard
output messages and stdr to print the
error messages the next component is
cluster now node.js is built upon the
concept of single threading programming
a single instance of node.js runs in a
single thread to take advantage of
multi-core systems the user will
sometimes want to launch a cluster of
node.js processes to handle the load a
cluster can be added to an application
in this way here's a small code for you
the next component is global now global
objects in node.js are available in all
modules now these objects are functions
modules strings etc some node.js global
objects are mentioned in the table you
have dir name that is the directory name
file name exports module and require the
next component is error handling now
nodejs applications experience four
types of errors we have the standard
javascript errors system errors user
specific errors and assertion errors now
errors in node.js are handled through
exceptions now for example let's handle
an error that would occur when we divide
a number by zero now this error would
crash the node.js application and so we
should handle this error here's a small
code for you
next up we have streaming a stream is an
abstract interface for working with
streaming data in node.js streams are
objects that let you read data or write
data continuously there are four types
of streams first one is the readable
these are these types of streams from
which data can be read writeable these
are the types of streams to which data
can be written
duplex these are both readable and
writable streams
lastly we have transform these streams
can manipulate the data while it is
being read or written moving on to the
next component buffer the javascript
language has no mechanism for reading or
manipulating streams of binary data
buffer is a module that allows handling
streams that contain only binary data an
empty buffer of length 10 can be created
by this method next up we have domain
domains provide a way to handle
different io operations as a single
group domain module intercepts errors
that remain unhandled there are two
types of methods that are used for
intercepting these errors firstly we
have internal binding in this case the
error emitter executes its code inside
the error method next up is the external
binding now here the error emitter is
explicitly added to a domain via its add
method the next component is the dns the
dns module enables name resolution for
example it is used to look up the ip
addresses of host names dns module is
used to connect to a dns server and
perform name resolution by using the
method dns.resolve the dns module is
also used for performing name resolution
without a network communication by using
the method dns.lookup the next component
is the debugger node.js includes an
out-of-process debugging utility
accessible via a v8 inspector and
built-in debugging client this node.js
debugger is not feature packed but
supports simple inspection of code it
can be used in the terminal by using the
inspect keyword before the name of the
javascript file in order to inspect a
file say myscript.js you can use the
following method now that we are
familiar with all the major parts of
node.js let's go ahead and learn about
the node.js express framework
express is a flexible node.js web
application framework that provides a
wide set of features to develop both web
and mobile applications you can assume
express as a layer built on top of the
nodejs that helps manage the server and
the roots now let's have a quick look at
some of the core features of express
framework it is used to design single
page multi-page and hybrid web
applications it allows setting up of
middleware to respond to http requests
it defines a routing table that is used
to perform different actions based on
the http method and url it also allows
dynamic rendering of html pages based on
passing arguments to templates now
moving on let's take a quick example of
a simple hello world program now this is
developed using express framework to
gain a better understanding all right
first up we have the var express now
this is used to import express framework
into a node.js application now the
app.get method is a callback function
with parameters request and response the
request object represents the http
request and has properties for the
request query string parameters body
http headers etc the response object
represents the http response that an
express app sends when it gets an http
request now the application will listen
to the defined port which in this case
is eight zero eight one and variables
host and port will contain the address
and the port respectively lastly we have
the console.log which is used to show
the address and port in the command
prompt so this is what the command
prompt would look like and finally the
output is displayed on the web browser
having learned about the express
framework now let's move on and look at
the node.js use cases
now it is no doubt that node stands out
for its speed and intensive data
exchange so top industry leaders like
nasa paypal netflix among others
incorporate node.js first up we have
netflix the world's leading internet
television network with over 117 million
users is one of the top companies that
trusted their services to node.js the
reasons why the company chose to use
node.js were application scalability and
data intensive application now you must
be wondering what application
scalability is it's basically the
potential of an application to grow in
time being able to efficiently handle
more and more requests per minute and
data intensive application allows
millions of people to stream netflix
simultaneously next up is walmart now
walmart is the world's largest company
by revenue with around 514 billion us
dollars according to the fortune global
500 list in 2019 again the reasons why
the company chose node.js were
asynchronous i o and efficient handling
of concurrent requests now asynchronous
io which is a form of input output
processing allows other processing to
continue before the transmission has
finished nodejs is able to efficiently
handle concurrent requests with the use
of thread pool and event queues uber
uber is an american multinational
ride-hailing company offering services
that include peer-to-peer ride sharing
ride service healing and food delivery
the reasons why the company chose
node.js were asynchronous i o quick
iterations and active open source
community as mentioned earlier
asynchronous io permits other processing
to continue before the transmission has
finished now quick iterations now
node.js is continually being updated and
added new features that help in further
improvement in the performance of web
servers and finally active open source
community resolves many problems that an
organization may face in a particular
scenario next up we have nasa now nasa
is an independent agency of the united
states federal government responsible
for the civilian space program as well
as aeronautics and aerospace research
the reasons why the company chose
node.js were reduced access times
handling of data intensive tasks and the
fact that the servers are active 24 7.
now nasa has lots and lots of data and
using node.js has really helped them in
reducing the access times it is also
continuously handling and working with
large streams of data node.js is highly
stable which helps in keeping the server
active 24 7. next up we have paypal now
paypal is an american company operating
a worldwide online payment system that
supports online money transfers as
opposed to traditional methods like
checks and money orders the reasons why
the company chose to use node.js for the
fact that node.js has extremely fast
bill times it allows tasks to be carried
out with fewer lines of code when
compared to other server technologies
like java and php and node.js being data
intensive efficiently handles a large
amount of data next up is medium medium
is a popular online publishing platform
developed by evan williams and launched
in august 2012. the main reasons why the
company chose to use node.js were a
data-driven applications now these
applications are ideal for being
interfaced with node.js servers b to run
a b tests now a b testing is essentially
an experiment where two or more variants
of a page are shown to users at random
and statistical analysis is used to
determine which variation performs
better lastly node.js server maintenance
is simpler than its counterparts moving
on to the last topic of this session
industry trends now node.js developers
are in demand across the globe since
many companies are adopting javascript
libraries according to forbes it is one
of the top 10 most in demand jobs
according to note source the total
number of node.js downloads increased by
40 in the last one year the use of
node.js in production has increased
dramatically since its release in 2010
with early adopters such as linkedin
paypal and netflix among others node.js
has seen an exponential increase in its
use in web development the popularity of
node.js is also accounted to javascript
now since javascript is the most popular
language as evident from a survey
conducted by stack overflow in 2019 many
developers can start working on node.js
library with not much of a learning
curve node.js developers are being
offered better salary options than other
web technology developers according to
pay scale the average salary of a
node.js developer in india is around 6
lakhs 13 000 rupees per year the average
salary of a node.js developer across the
united states is around 105 000 us
dollars per year in this video we'll
help you install node.js on your windows
system so without further ado let's
begin the first thing you need to do is
download node.js from their official
website
so go ahead and type download
node.js
navigate to their official website
and here
you can see the 64-bit version so go
ahead and download that once the
download is done go ahead and run the
downloaded node.js installer
accept the license agreement keep the
default settings as it is
and then say install
so with that we finished the
installation process
once node has been successfully
installed the next crucial step is
verification now this process ensures
that node has been properly installed
to do so we first open the command
prompt and then type in a few commands
to verify the successful installation we
type in this command
node hyphen v now this command returns
the version and if it returns the
version it means it has been
successfully installed
so here we go it returns the latest
version
now the final step is to update the node
package manager now this npm is bundled
with nodejs which consists of all the
repositories and packages required for
development purposes so to do that type
in the command
npm
install
npm
hyphen hyphen
global now that we're done with the
installation of node let's go ahead and
implement a small program for that we
make use of a text editor in our case
we've installed vs code so go ahead and
download vs code once you're done with
the installation this is what via score
looks like so go ahead and click on file
and create a new file it's going to be a
simple program where you're going to
print a hello world message on the web
browser to do that we make use of http
modules so node comes with built-in http
modules to transfer data across it
so for that we make use of a require
method we create a variable first say
var
http
equals required
and just say http within single quotes
now the http module can create an http
server that listens to the server ports
and gives a response back to the client
to do that we make use of the create
server method
so let's go ahead and type the code
say
http dot create
server and internally it consists of a
function
now the parameters to this function are
request and response now the response is
basically used to write to the client so
we say response dot write and here we
type in the message say hello world
welcome
to this tutorial
once you're done with that you end the
response
so the server listens to a port number
to display the message by default it
listens to the port number 8080 so we
keep that as it is and we end it save
your file
say
demo.js maybe demo1.js and say save now
to run the program you have to open the
command prompt so open your command
prompt
and mention the path to your file so in
our case it's our desktop on the desktop
so cd
desktop and now to run it say node
demo1 dot js now you navigate to your
browser
and say localhost 8080 and here we go
our message is successfully displayed so
let's talk about the node.js
architecture and understand why it's so
good
so to begin with node.js has what's
called a single threaded event loop
architecture and this allows you to be
able to handle
many many concurrent clients at the same
time it's just a very flexible way of
being able to scale up your support for
many clients
and then in addition to that we have the
javascript event based model along with
the javascript callback mechanism that
allows you to have this standard
approach to being able to connect with
and talk and discuss interactions
between the client and the server it's
good to have these kind of standards
where you're not using something that's
unique to a specific framework or a
specific technology this just makes it
so it's a more accessible for everybody
so if we look at the actual node.js
server itself everything centers around
the the concept of the event loop and
the event loop has a a
an event queue an operation completed
and fire requests threaded pull and then
it'll actually do the actual computation
or the file system interaction
all of this interconnects in a nice
seamless loop the great thing again with
node.js is that it's not new technology
it's been around for almost a decade
it's very very well tried out many of
the largest websites out there are
running node.js
so let's now dig into each of the parts
of the node.js architecture so let's
talk about requests
so the way that the request works is
that you have your framework uh such as
angular
on the client and that will then send a
request to the website and there's many
ways that those requests can happen
through web workers through forms and
through other interactions
but at some point a request is sent to
the server
and so these requests can be for data
they can be for deleting data they can
be for updating data they can be for
interacting with services as mentioned
before but the goal is to have some kind
of request now once that request
actually hits the server and then we
start actually getting into the cueing
and threading process that centers
around the event loop and this is where
node.js really excels because it's able
to use that single threaded model to be
able to manage from just even a few
requests to tens of millions of requests
so it receives the actual request and
starts the event queue and this is where
a single threading process starts is by
queuing everything up appropriately
and then it then maintains the thread
within a pool so you have the cueing
process as one action and then you have
a threaded pool which manages those um
threads as well
and then we have an event loop which you
know goes through actually receives and
processes those requests
and then finally what we're doing is
we're actually they're going to be
interacting with a system and that could
be a database it could be a cloud system
it could be an api file system but we're
interacting with something that's
outside of the node.js server so the
node.js server itself is doing some
actions on the server
but then it's also interact with things
outside of its own server environment
and so let's talk a little bit about
that workflow
so requests come in they go into the
event queue and they get spiraled
through the event loop and then we have
a non-blocking operators which are going
to be doing the input output polling
such as kq epoll and other services and
from there we're also going to be then
interacting with the threaded pool and
we're using the blocking operations to
manage that threaded pool
and that threaded pool is going to now
then go outside of the server and
interact with something beyond the
server so whether that is a database or
file system or api or microservice these
are things that can be interacted with
so let's go through what npm is
so npm itself stands for the node
package manager no
great shakes there as the name says it's
responsible for all the packages and
modules that are bundled within node.js
so the notepad manager itself really has
two key functionalities and the first is
that reply it is a central repository
for all packages and modules which you
can then search through um online you
can go to search.nodejs.org
and you can find all of the packages and
modules that are out there
the second is that it's also a command
line or terminal uh line utility that
allows you to install those packages so
you can actually go through and you can
see the version management dependencies
within those packages and you actually
can control the packages themselves
so why would you use npm
so npm is really useful for being able
to extend the project you're working on
so when you're building out a project
one of the concepts i like to use is the
concept of lego bricks um big fan of
lego and
what's great about lego bricks is that
they're all individually by themselves
very small very specific functionality
um but if you actually get a whole
collection of lego bricks together you
can build like crazy cool things so
think of when you're working with the
node package manager itself is that each
of those individual pieces that you're
working with
each of those individual packages are
their own lego bricks and by themselves
you can then edit and update and
maintain that piece
separately from the whole environment as
long as your inputs and outputs they
have really the piece where you snap the
lego in or when you connect lego to
something else um are interactive and
open and well documented then you can
actually then use those modules
effectively throughout your project
um so you can actually then being able
to you do that you can do version
control on your codes and dependencies
you can do testing very easily
and then once you actually get to the
point where you go yes i want to release
um a new module you can do that
effectively using npm and it will
actually go through and do the actual
deployment for you
so let's go through the npm installation
so the actual package manager itself is
included with the installation of
node.js so if you've installed and
you're running node.js
locally then you've already installed
the package manager but you can also
access it through command line or
terminal window on your data server or
in your server farm or in via the cloud
if you haven't now downloaded node.js
here's the website where you can go down
to install it and there's windows and
mac versions of that
code as well with the installers which
allow you to get up and going very
quickly uh you want to be able to run
the installer and accept all the default
settings just um you know to begin with
you want to kind of have the standard
setup so that you are most familiar with
the normal settings before you start
getting to the point where you're a
master and you're tweaking things
um there is a way that you can open up
the command window or the terminal
window
and once you've actually installed
node.js and to verify that it's actually
installed you can write the command node
dash dash version and i'll show them
pull out the version of node.js that you
have installed and then you'll be able
to see that you've got you're actually
up and running
and then you can also do the same thing
for npm we can do npm dash dash version
and it actually will then show you which
version of the node package manager you
have running so you can actually take it
full advantage of that program and
verify that it's actually up and running
so let's actually look inside of a
package so packages themselves are
actually just json files if you're new
to this space json file is a structured
file format uh that's based on
javascript it's a very xml like format
for being able to
write instructions for the actual
package itself and so the json file
forms that you know really kind of the
the heart of each package you create
it has all of the metadata that you'd
have about a particular object
and then it provides a root directory to
any of the applications or modules
that the package may be referencing
um in addition and it has any other
additional
information about the project that such
as dependencies and other files that
need to be included so here we have is
an example of a package that would be
created
using npm json
script and you can actually take this
package file as it is right here um and
use um the command npm in it and it'll
actually run this package and so you
actually have a demo application up and
running really quickly uh you can then
go ahead if you want to you can edit any
of these parameters so like for instance
if you wanted to change the description
or the version uh or what is the the
main index script that would be written
you know these are all things that you
can edit very quickly and easily you can
just use text editor to make any of
these edits
and so we have the different metadata
that can be updated
and so this is where we go in and do a
full demo of working
with npm
so what we're going to do now is we're
actually going to go ahead and actually
run a demo of using npm and to do that
i've got three windows in front of me
right now so i have this window here
which is my terminal window
where i'll be doing all my instructions
then i also have a
folder which shows where i'll be putting
all of the files and then finally i'll
actually have a text editor in this case
i'm using vs code because it's free
but you can use any text editor you like
to be able to go in and show what the
code that's been created
by npm in the json file so you can
actually see what it looks like
and then we'll modify it a little bit so
first thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead and create a
new project folder so i'm going to go in
i'm just going to move
into i'm going to do
change directory i'm going to
the project folder
and we'll see down here that we have an
empty project folder um but for this one
i'm actually going to go ahead and i'm
going to create a new directory in this
one and i'm going to call this one
simply learn
and there we are we've created a new
simple event folder
and we are going to
move into the simplyland folder
and so we're now in the simplyland
folder uh there's nothing in that right
now so the first thing we want to do is
we want to take go ahead and initialize
this folder as a project folder for
working with npm now to do this you will
have have to already installed npm if
you have no js npm comes with it
and if you want to see whether or not
you have npm installed so you can just
do npm
version
and that will actually tell you what the
version of npm you have installed is it
also verifies that npm is installed so
i've gone ahead and i've been able to
validate that i have npm installed so
what i'm now going to go ahead and do is
i'm going to initialize this folder so
to do that you just do npm init and
you'll see that the path is that we're
already in the simplyland folder and
then when you do that
it's going to ask you some questions so
what is the package name we're going to
go with the defaults for right now and i
can show you how we can edit those in a
little bit uh we're going to go with
just say yes to all of these just by
hitting return
and you'll see here that we're going to
create a new folder called a
package.json folder this is the
instructions that we have in the folder
do you want to go ahead and create this
you want to and it's going to go ahead
and do that and we can see now in our
folder here that we actually have
package.json so we go ahead and open
this up with
vs code
here we are we can actually see what all
of the information is we can go ahead
and we can actually go and update
this metadata if we want to i'm going to
leave it as is for right now because i
want to show you a couple of other
things so a lot of times when you're
actually working with npm
and the reason why you're using npm is
that you want to take advantage of
packages that are freely available in
the open source community that are
supported by node.js and one of those is
a package called express and express is
a lightweight framework for building out
web applications similar concept uh to
angular or react js um i like using it
and it's also a great way to be able to
show how we can
install this using npm so to install
this uh you just start with the command
npm and then you type install
and then we type the name of the package
and we hit
enter
and it goes ahead
and what you'll actually see
is a couple of things one is we have a
dependency in our package above
we also have
so this is in our json package that is
now dependency it's written in there
we can also go in and under our node
modules we actually see that we have
we scroll down we should see express
there it is express
now if we decide that we don't want to
use um express we can actually just come
in and we can write command npm
uninstall
i can type
express
oops i did a typo there so let's try
that again npm
uninstall
express
and a couple of things going to happen
one is
in our json file the dependency for the
express file has now been removed
and we can also see that under our node
modules there are no extensions there
so this is kind of cool this allows us
to be able to see
that we can
easily add and remove packages
so let's just go ahead and i'm going to
install express again so
install
express
oops
npm install express
all right so it's gone ahead and it's
installed express
now one of the things that will often
happen is that when you're working with
a package the actual json package so
you'll receive
this file
and you want to be able to go ahead and
install of the
sub modules that come with it so and you
can go through you can manually install
them like this or you can actually run
an install command so you can actually
install all of them at once i can just
show you what that looks like
because we're going to actually go ahead
and simulate as if we're going to
install bootstrap which is another
popular framework
stream
and we're actually going to go with
and then we'll save that
and what we'll see is under the packages
that bootstrap isn't listed in there we
do have
express there it is right there
so we now come over to
our
new commands we can actually write the
command
npm install
and now
site typo let's try that again
let's do npm
install
okay it does help to save your file so
let's go ahead and
let's run npm install
and when you do that what we'll now
actually have is not just
express but
we'll also see that bootstrap has also
been added
now i don't recommend that you use the
star symbol which will install the
latest version of bootstrap because you
obviously haven't tested your
application against that but it gives
you an idea of
what's happened here now if we want to
we can actually go in here and we can
see
on in
install
bootstrap
and it will actually remove that from
your json package so there we are that's
how you work with using npm from getting
started with a
setup for a base initialization of your
package going through to creating the
first package
being able to set up and control the
naming convention for each of the items
within the metadata that provides the
instruction for
the package how you can then put in
dependencies such as express and
bootstrap how you can install them and
remove them and actually use do all of
this through command line if you have
any questions
please let us know
so let's kind of jump into the express
js framework
so express.js is a really flexible
node.js and web application framework it
is just something you can spin up very
quickly and build both web and mobile
applications just a really great tool um
you know i use it all the time for
building up my own applications
um the thing that's so great about it is
it's really simple and so
it's not going to be as have all the the
functionality that you would have in
maybe a larger scale http service
but with that said it does come with a
lot of functionality that allows you to
not only create websites but you can
also do apis and other routing calls
very very nice
so let's go through some of the features
that express express.js have
so as i mentioned before it allows you
to build simple web applications and
that can be either a single page
application or a multi-page application
it also allows you to do middleware
requests and responses so for instance
if you want to do an api um and have
that be part of your middleware you can
actually set that up real quickly in
fact in the demo that we'll do later on
we'll actually be building out four
different api calls that you'll be able
to do and you'll be able to see how you
can use express.js for that
um and that in then turns allows you to
be able to see how express.js can help
manage some of the routing of the
different
http methods that you'd be using via url
and then finally it's just a great way
of being able to
dynamically test the work that you are
developing so you can actually build out
a solution and test it right away and
express js have it in a single packet
and then once you get to a certain point
you can then check in the whole packet
uh even have it as part of your
container
and then check that into your
main
project
and then if somebody else wants to then
take on the work they can then just pull
that in
so let's kind of go step through you
know a basic example so here we actually
have a full script for creating a simple
hello world and this includes installing
express.js
defining the ports it's going to run on
as well as a basic piece of code so the
first thing you want to do is actually
go ahead and define how you want to
install express.js and this is called
the very first variable which is
requiring that express be installed as
part of node packet manager
uh npm will then pull in the latest
version of express if you need to define
a specific version of course you can do
that
in this example we're just going to pull
the latest one and then we'll go ahead
and with the second line which will then
install express and when you do it once
you'll see how quickly it installs onto
your local development machine
the next parameters are actually a
callback function so if something
actually happens when you go to the
website where we're going to run our web
application you want something to pop up
and in this instance we'll say hello it
will pop up
the third block is all about where you
would actually go ahead and host your
code and so in this one you'll see that
the uh server is going to listen and
listen to port 8081 so that's what that
function entity there defines
and then you can either put in uh the a
specific host address
in the demo you'll actually see how we
define that for localhost but you can
actually then point this to a production
host environment if you want
and then the final line here is a
command that actually sent a
script to your terminal window telling
you that which port and which host that
you are listening to so let's see what
that would look like so here we go see
have our terminal window and we're
actually able to then
run the hello world js script that we
just uh wrote and then once we do that
it'll actually then post that we have an
example app listening at and here we
don't have a
web domain address and we do have the
port 8081
and in our browser window it says hello
world
so that's a quick breakdown of express
js now let's jump over and do a demo
so the first thing we want to do to get
express up and running on our system is
we have to have node.js installed so
we're just going to do a google search
to let you know where you can find
node.js it's actually at nodejs.org
so we select that link that'll take us
to nodejs.org and there are two types of
downloads one is the current download
which has
the latest features and then there's a
more stable version that if you're new
to node.js i'd recommend you to download
next we want to find a text editor and
we're going to go with visual studio
code or vs code as known
it's an open source solution from
microsoft that runs across all the
leading platforms so this will default
to our windows platform but you can run
it on mac os and linux as well i really
like it it's a great code editor it
comes a lot of extensions and it's open
source
next thing you want to do is because
we're going to be developing apis we
want a way to be able to visualize those
apis quickly and a great tool is a
product called postman
again open source and so you can go out
and go to postman.com
top right hand corner you'll see a
bright orange download button where you
can actually go and head and download
and install postman and that will allow
you to be able to access
all of your apis that we're going to be
creating in express
you can actually use other tools such as
apigee as well for visualizing your apis
but this one's just great to get you
started so let's go ahead and open up
vs code and we want to go ahead and open
a new folder where we're going to have
our project we're going to just for
our demonstration here we're going to
put this on the desktop you wouldn't
normally do this but it'll work fine
here i'm going to create a folder i'm
going to title the file the node express
and we'll select that folder that now
becomes the root folder for our project
in
visual studio
we don't really need the the welcome
screen anymore so we're going to get rid
of that
and one of the things that is great
about working with vs code is you can
actually have the terminal window up and
running as well so let's go ahead and
open that so it's running at the bottom
of our screen and this gives us a little
bit of space
and the first thing we want to do is
actually turn convert the folder in
actually into a project running node.js
so we're going to use npm in it and that
will actually initialize the project we
have another video that explains how to
use npm or node package manager and you
can go ahead and find that um in our
library here
but as we go ahead and we do that you'll
actually see that it will create the
default package
json file which has the
name of the folder is the default name
of the package but you can actually go
in and edit any of these documents
we want to create a default file that's
called index.js
this is where we're going to write most
of our scripts that allow us to work
with node.js
and the first is writing a script that
allows us to install express and
we'll use the node packet manager to
actually pull and install express and
you can default to specific versions of
express if you want and we're just going
to go with the latest one so we're just
going to put in express and then we'll
go down into terminal window and say npm
install
save express and this will install
express so we can actually test out the
code we're working on
and let's take just a moment to install
great thing with working with node
package manager is that once we've
finished with our package here we can
actually wrap it all up and send it over
to any other developer that we're
working with and then you can actually
run the the package and actually have
exactly the same code installed
and there we are we have everything
installed and ready to go
you can see we actually have all the
modules installed you see that we
actually have express installed as well
and we also want to then make this an
app
and then we'll do app
listen
to port 3000 so this is by default we're
going to be running from our local host
which is http server running on
this test machine and we're going to
have express for this project
run on port 3000
and in the once we actually run the
script we'll actually uh post into the
console um window a
piece of text saying server started on
port 3000
so we're going to go ahead and save this
file
a little control s to save these files
so let's go into localhost in our web
browser so localhost colon sorry yeah
it's localhost
and you'll see nothing has been reached
that's because we actually haven't done
anything to initialize the script so we
want to come in and we're going to go
nodeindex.js and hit return
and as you can see now we have a message
in our console window that means that
yep there we go we actually have
everything up and running
so we can actually see that the service
is running not a very pleasant message
so let's go ahead and change that
so let's change that to
app get
and
[Music]
acquire res
and so if you use the get message let's
change
what we'll print
and we'll type
hello
there
exclamation mark
and we save that
and we refresh the screen
oh nothing happening again because we
didn't run the script let's go back in
and we'll run the script node index.js
and now what you'll see is if we refresh
there we are we have our new hello there
message
all right well let's actually start
building some apis in this environment
so to be able to build the apis we want
to be able to pull
content so we can actually
create a new file called users.js
and we're going to create
we're going to go ahead and create a a
user's json packet and adjacent packet
is essentially a
an array um
consider it like a small database and in
this array we're going to have four
objects each object is going to have
three pieces of metadata we have an id
name and email
and they'll be
id 1 2 and 3 and then you'll see that
the names will be
john smith and
we'll make up a couple of others i'm
just kind of giving them arbitrary
email addresses
it's just for our demo here
let me grab this copy it
kind of speed up
the script writing time
there we go
and let's just change what we need
and one of the things that's nice with
working with the visual studio
code vs code is there's lots of plugins
and so one of the default features is
that if you
select a variable it'll actually look
for the same variable in the script so
you can if you need to you can actually
change them all in
once
but we don't need to worry about that
right now we're just creating
a json packet so we have four items
id one two three and four
for john smith and jack and chris
all right so that's our
array string and we're gonna then make
sure that we can export that as
users so we can actually now whenever we
select the term users in our scripts
it'll actually pull in this packet
all right looking
good now let's go over to our main
index.js file and we're just going to go
ahead and we want to
like
store where
the the api is going to be so we're
going to create a
folder called routes and then a
subfolder called api
and then we'll call a file in there
called users.js so as we're updating our
scripts we know where to
pull the data from
it's just a standard way of being able
to pull out the values so in here we're
going to say
in this instance express is required
for our scripts
and we're going to also say that
router
within express router
correct
naming convention
and the script is case sensitive we'll
also want to create a value later on
that will have a unique id so we're
actually going to
pull in a uuid
package that will actually then allow us
to install
unique identifiers so we use node
package manager to install
uuid
again this is a great example of how you
can go from nothing to something very
quickly
with exp
node.js because we installed express we
installed uuid and we're off to the
races
so let's have users require
the path for where
our api is going to be located
all right so let's do a basic get
which will be to pull the record so
we're going to have it pull
all the records so router.get and
we're going to require it to pull all
the records in the json packet that we
created
so there should be four items to come
back
save that
looks good
make sure that users is consistent
there's our adjacent packet
and
yep everything looking pretty good
all right let's go back to index
and we're going to switch out
this function here from just a generic
get with a generic
statement to actually being able to pull
in the users so
we have to go
app
use express.json
don't use
url encoded
extended
false
amp dot use
api
users so
you're going to be pulling them all from
the same location
require
and where we have our api
scripts
okay
and then let's go ahead and open up
postman because we're going to actually
use postman to actually show us what the
results look like because right now the
results
won't show up appropriately
um in our browser window
so placement again is just a api
management tool if you used apigee or
other similar tools that are on the
market mulesoft
you'll see it's very consistent again
this is open source
and
what you want to be able to do is you
can actually go
and actually go to the path where the
api is stored
and then you can use all the different
types of commands within
your
environment to be able to you know test
out the scripts so let's go ahead and
create a new project a new request and
we go with the default get but there's
actually quite a lot of different
commands we can use
and these are just http commands
and we're going to type in the request
and in this instance
it's going to be
let's run our script first
[Music]
let's make sure we're exporting the data
correctly
okay
so we want to run our script so let's do
node index.js and that will
run the changes that we just created so
we can now come over to get we select
api um localhost colon3000
slash api
users
when we do
that brings back
the
json package with our four
entry points
there there's all four of them
so that's your
first action
now let's kind of get this a little bit
tighter let's actually go in and see if
we can filter by id
so we're going to go in and we're going
to modify our script so it's going to be
route
and then we're going to put in the
filter and in this instance it's going
to be id
which would allow us to be able to just
put a backslash against the
end of the url string we just had and
put in a number or a unique identifier
and then that will actually then allow
us to pull in that unique record
[Music]
the data
okay so if found
i want to
take the json and
print it
so we're going to filter here against
user id
and then
publish the results
else if it doesn't work then we'll just
have a
generic
error message
we shouldn't see this though in the
demos we're creating
this is just
good practice
so save that
and let's go ahead and rerun
our node index file against that
folder
and now we can actually come in here and
do backslash one and that will give us
just one record
and we could change that to two or one
hundred in this instance and if it's a
hundred
we'll just get a bad request error
message
there's two
all right
so that's
get so we've been able to pull all the
records we need to filter against one
specific record against a specific
parameter in this instance it was id
so let's go ahead and create a new user
so that what we're going to do for this
is we're going to use the post
command from http to actually push and
post data into
the data source the data sources are
json packet which means that we'll have
to then push a new record into the json
package
using our array statements
because json's just essentially an array
and so we're going to
post and when we do this we have to
create a unique id so this is where we
have to reference the uid
i'm going to do a v4
unique id
which will be
four groups of four so these 16
characters
and then
we'll have
name
and email we'll post
okay looks good
okay
so
if
new user
input dot name
and
new user
dot email
and then we want to return
the results
okay
all right and so users
dot
push so we post it which is a http
statement and then pushing into the
the json packet array
okay
okay it's looking good
all right so
i think we're good
let's go ahead and rerun our script
nodeindex.js
that allows us to do that so let's go to
postman so we can actually connect to
the url i'm going to change
the http statement to post
and
get rid of that go back to users now if
we just do this
nothing's gonna happen so we actually
have to go in and we have to update the
body
and this would be the content that will
be passed through and we're going to go
through with a raw
statement here
and we do json this will be
that's the packet we're sending so let's
go ahead and the records we want to
update we only have to update two which
is one is name and the second is email
we don't have to do an id because we're
using uuid to generate an automatic one
for us
and we're going to create records for
staff and her email address is steph
gmail.com
yep looking good
okay so let's go ahead and send that
we sent it
and if we look at the bottom we can
actually now see that we have five
records so a new one's been added we
have our unique id at the top
and then we have name and email which
are the ones that we just created for
staff and staff at gmail.com
all right
so that's posting now the next thing you
want to do is to update a record so that
means we need to select an id
and then be able to update the content
and for that we're going to use the http
put command
so we'll use id as our way to be able to
filter
and then we'll be able to update against
that filter
so
construct found
because
users
and then
we'll have it going against
users id
so we know how to get the correct record
and then pass the record back
onto the screen so we know what we're
editing
so if
so if failed
want to update
the user
and i'm going to go ahead and pull
information from the body for what will
be updated
and for each
diffuser id
then pass
the integer
okay
so this is our values to pass against
the id
and in this instance we'll make sure
that we're updating the values of
username
so if we are
updating user
and we're just updating the username you
want to
make sure that that's the value that
gets updated
and then we also want to do user email
we don't want to update the id so it's
going to remain unique and consistent
okay and we're gonna make sure that
everything is pushed to the
json package
and then we'll also have a message
saying that
the field has been updated in the json
package
okay
all right so we'll run that script again
and looks good let's go to our folder
let's change the http
post let's put it as get
just so we can see that we have
uh all of the values in the array from
the json packet
and now we want to select put which
allows us to
update just
one record
so let's go ahead and select one record
we'll select it1 so
we have one record we can go ahead and
for name we can change this
let's go ahead and change these
so now you see that the email has
changed so we have staff
as the new account
all right our final api that we're going
to create
is to delete an account and in many ways
it's actually a very basic api because
what we're doing is we're grabbing the
id and they were saying that all the
associated records with that id
um within
that row
as it were in the table just to delete
the whole row
and so
we want to use
again
our id as
the unique value that we're
pulling against
so we're going to if users are found
and we're going to
filter those users
i'm going to do that filter against user
id
and
pass that
and
let go and
post a message to our json packet saying
user
deleted
no
generic message if things fail
okay let's save that and we'll
see we go ahead and we're using we're
just deleting the record now
and we're going to do it by filtering
against a unique id
and then you will then just
eliminate that record
we'll pass the message that has been
the account has been deleted
okay so save that let's go run our
script
node index.js
we're good okay has come over here and
we're going to
show that we can pull any of the
accounts so let's just take one of them
one that's good
so let's go ahead and we're going to
change
the http command to delete
and we actually have to
select an account so we just do
one
when we do that it'll actually delete
that record and here we are
it says that the user has been deleted
and we now only have
three records in the jason packet
and we can pull all the records
and you'll see that there's only three
so being able to
pull all the records from a json package
we'll be able to create a record update
a record and delete a record
and we can just step through so here's
our json package that we created
originally again this is just an array
it's just a different way of setting up
the array
and then we have our index files which
um identifies what are the apps that
need to be installed and where are the
apis going to be
serviced out of
and that we're going to be doing this on
uh the port 3000
um again these are additional tools that
we need to make sure and that we have up
and running um in our script and so the
first script was to get all the um the
records is to filter against a user id
for just a specific record
and then for creating a record we
actually went in and we used the uid
tool to create a unique identifier and
then we posted in the data for the new
records we did something similar with
updating the record we didn't have to
update the user id we just had to update
the values in
the two fields that we needed to be
updated
in this case name and email
and the final step was to go ahead and
delete a record so these are all
apis that you can now pull into your own
application so you can use them in web
applications or you can actually go
ahead and use them in other applications
such as mobile applications
local applications and other scripts and
this really allows your application to
become
more scalable and more useful
hello and we're going to go through and
do our demo of building a restful api
with node.js so the first thing we want
to do is go ahead and install all the
correct pieces of software we'll start
with node.js so let's do a google search
on node.js and you'll find that
node.js is at
nodejs.org so we select that link
and that's going to take us to the
node.js website and there are two
versions of node.js you can download
there's the stable version and then
there's the latest version i'd go with
the stable version you'll find it
available in windows mac os and linux as
well
and if we go to the next piece of
software we want to go ahead and install
the text editor of your choice um i'm
going to use visual studio code vs code
it's an open source solution it works on
all leading platforms
works really well i like it a lot
microsoft did a good job with this i
also really like it that it's open
source
but there's lots of extensions you can
get for vs code so it's a great text
editor
and we'll also need postman postman is a
tool that allows us to be able to view
the apis that we're going to create so
let's go ahead to postman.com and again
it's another
solution you can download for free and
so we're going to go ahead and select
the download button
and it will automatically detect which
os you're on so in this case this can be
windows but you can also get mac and
linux as well so we'll go ahead and
download those
and once we have everything installed
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a project in vs code and that's
actually really easy to do all you have
to do is create a folder
and we do this right off our desktop
and we're going to call the folder node
rest api and we'll select that folder
and you'll see on the left hand column
that we have the new folder that we
created we still have the vs code
welcome screen we get rid of that we
don't need that anymore so
let's go ahead and one of the things i
like with vs code is you can actually
toggle the terminal window so let's go
ahead and open up the terminal window so
we can actually run that at the same
time and so we're going to
move our cursor to the folder we just
created and there we are you see that
and what we can do now is we're going to
initialize this with node package
manager
to make this a package
and it's going to go ahead i'm going to
ask for a name we're just going to go
with the default so we're just going to
say yes yes to a couple of these
yep enter
and turn enter
enter and turn
and turn
and it's okay yep enter
all right so now we have a new file and
this is our json package it has all the
defaults in it we can go in and modify
these if you want to i have no need to
for this exercise but you may want to
for the solution that you're putting
together
and we're going to create a new file
called index.js
and this is going to be the reference
file that's in the json package
for npm
and here we're going to put in our
solutions that we absolutely have to
have
for this to run so we're going to
install express and express
is a web service application it's very
flexible and one of the things that
we're going to use it for today is build
apis
so in our terminal window we're going to
type npm install
save express
this will install express locally on our
machine
and takes a few minutes but it's going
to go and download all the latest
features this is going to be the latest
version of express you can if you want
to
specify a specific version of software
for these examples there's no need to do
that
so you'll see that everything has been
installed we expand the the node module
we can scroll down and indeed yep there
we are we see express has been installed
along with some other
pieces that are useful
all right so that's our first piece
and the next
is we're going to define our app and our
app is going to
use express
and we want express as a local host on
our local machine on port 3000 so we've
identified port 3000 as the default
port for our application
and
we are going to now create
a an array
for some movies
i'm going to have id title director and
release date
section great movie
and director christopher
nolan
and
i was released
in 2010 yes 10 years ago
okay so we're going to do an a couple of
items here and just so that we
have some more than one entry in our
array and an array is a javascript
uh you can think of it as a very simple
table now it allows us to have
structured data
uh you can also do a json file you can
also connect to
a database mongodb or something like
that
2019.
okay so we have two movies in our
little array
that'd be more than enough right now
uh key part is that we have
a consistent structure for the array of
id title director and release date
and so we're going to
create
two
apis one is going to be a get api where
we'll get the list
of the items in our api and the second
will be a post where we'll be actually
pushing in a new item so let's go ahead
and start with the get and what we're
going to do is we're going to say get
slash movie
and
we are going to
have this run as an api and so
what we'll do is we will test this in a
moment
this will be running from our web
browser and actually we'll probably yeah
open up the postman and run this through
postman so
okay
that pause all the movies
and we'll do a another um
get in a moment where we'll filter by
movie id but let's just get them all for
right now
and we are going to
[Music]
listen on a server port in this instance
it's going to be port 3000
and
we already had defined the port as a
variable earlier um which
so we're just referencing the variable
and the port number is listed at the
top in line four
just a text string that's going to get
put to the terminal window
and it is going to dynamically
grab the port the value from the
variable from 3000
and place it in our text string easy
and we want to save the file
and now we're going to go ahead and run
it so we're going to do node index.js
that runs the script
and tells us that we're listening on
port 3000 that's great
that means now that we should be able to
go into postman
and
grab the data from an api
so here's postman if you've not used it
before it's a great tool for being able
to manage apis i strongly encourage you
to have a go with this so we're going to
get the get command and you've done any
applications web applications you've
probably used get and post
for
the data that you're
pulling and pushing from forms online
same principle
so we want to go ahead and we're going
to go and
grab get i'm going to type in localhost
and
it's going to be colon 3000 slash
movies because that's the
the name of the
file
and we hit send and
what we get as a response
is the
data in our query
sorry in our array here we go so there's
our array and the data values have been
pulled back by postman
that's great
so now we want to go ahead and add a
movie
to our array
and we're going to do that we're going
to use the
post
command
and get and post our http
commands
and so we're going to use movies
and
in this instance
we're going to
push the value
into
our list
so construction movie requires we're
going to need
a structure here and that structure is
going to be
the information that's in there the body
and then we're gonna
push to
the log
our terminal window
and
push
so here we're using
push
and that's a term in for arrays within
javascript where we push the data into
the actual array itself
there are lots of ways of being able to
control data within an array and if
you're new to arrays with javascript i
strongly encourage you to
learn more about them there's just an
awful lot you can do with them
and then we want to have a validation
message come up on the screen saying yes
movie has been added to the list so
we'll save what we've just created and
we don't save it it won't show up and
then we're going to rerun
the
node index.js file
you'll see this we've created here
already
a an api
that allows us to pull and push data
in and out of a variable
okay so let's go back and we're going to
change the
header from being get to being push
so we're going to use sorry not push our
post so we're going to select post and
then what we want to do is the
value inside of the body
and so let's go over
and we want to change select body
and we're playing text
and select json so it's going to be
structured
and so here we will essentially copy the
structure we have here so let's go ahead
and just
copy these elements
and we have to give it an id because we
don't have an auto generated id so i'm
going to make this id
3
and
[Music]
then it's going to be a number three
and then you want to put in
title
new movie
opening
director
and
we'll have this as
i don't know
new
director
not very creative here today
and then
we need to put in a date
so release underscore dates
let's just put in a date
uh today's date will be fine
um just so you know that we're not
formatting the datecon
so let's go ahead and we'll select send
and this will actually go and we can see
boom movies been added to our list
then we can go back and let's go ahead
and validate that so we're going to
change from post to get
use the same
and
now we go to below
oh looks like we put an error in
our formatting
so let's go
to
pass the json
and we will pass it using express
and this will
clear up any formatting issues
so
app.use express json
express
url
encoded extended
false
and this should help us pass
our
value
and then we'll rerun that script
make sure you save the previous file
otherwise you won't run the new script
all right looking good so let's go back
and let's go back to
our
localhost 3000
movies
and there's only two values here
so what we need to do now is change from
get to post
we'll go to body
and what we're going to do is we want to
have
raw jason
and
what we want to do is capture the values
that we have below
and insert
this
file into this new
json packet
into
our array
let you just copy that
it's a little bit cheating but it's
remain same so let's go ahead
and
get everything consistent
and we'll change the number to three
we're creating a unique title badging
sorry new type of doesn't need to be
unique just the id needs to be unique
so title new movie
director change it to new director
i'm going to change the date
i'm not doing any formatting on the data
any date any number really
hit save
movie's been added to our list
so it's been added but now let's go back
to get and let's see if we can actually
see the third entry and scroll down
and there we are we've actually pushed
that
json package into our array
so we now have three items in
the opening added fire our api
okay
so
now let's go ahead and search
our movie database i guess we only have
three entries but you know we want to be
able to so we can do that by using the
get command and what we'll be doing is
we'll be validating against
a specific id number
so we have three
and we're going to
validate against
just the id number
in this instance um the way to do it is
through the url so beforehand we had
localhost colon 3000 slash movie now
we're adding in a slash movie slash and
then whatever number after we'll
actually filter against the id
and
that's essentially what we're doing here
right now
so we go into f movies
dot id again we're using the id value to
actually
pull from our array list
with my variables and arrays mixed up
here today
and then once we actually have the value
we'll actually post back as a json
packet
and
if we have any errors then what we'll do
is we'll throw up message movie not
sound so
there we are we're going to pull against
an id
and we should be able to then pull that
up
through postman
into
our terminal window
again the reason why we're using postman
is that this is actually just showing
the values going back and forth we're
not having to render a whole web page
it's extremely fast very efficient
all right
so we saved and rerun our script
all right let's go back and what we're
going to do is we're going to change the
value so we're going to hit send here we
are we see all of our movies using the
get command now what we're going to do
is we're going to use a look filter on
just
id2 which is the irishman so do slash 2
and there we are we have just the
information on the irishman
so now you can see how you can create a
simple search
all right
so the final action we want to do is to
delete a record
in our array
and so
we can go ahead and do that
and we're going to use the
delete commands to actually do that so
uh we've been able to push
um
in a
record we've been able to
view records filter guide games records
now we're going to go ahead and do
delete and so you can do app delete and
then we're going to filter by
specific id number
and when we do this we'll actually then
uh when we put in the url path which
will be localhost colon thousand slash
movie slash and then the id number so
this is inside that one or two probably
use two
that will then
uh delete from
our array
the record for the irishman
let's see
i do have a shortcut and a keyboard
shortcut of control plus s
to save files on
windows or command plus s on my mac
and
once we've deleted a record we want to
send a message saying the movie has been
deleted
all right so we want to go ahead
and
let's just check our code
good save our file
and we want to re-run
the
index.js file
yep
rerun okay let's go to postman
and grab
the delete
so again we're filtering against the
movie id and then we'll delete that id
okay so we went against the argument
and we hit send
and there it is
now we're going to change
the command to delete
so we hit
one will actually delete conception
movie has been deleted it's great
and let's go ahead and grab
our use get to
pull in all the movies that
are listed and it's not going to find
movie number with the id id1 it's not
there anymore
and if we get all the movies
we see we only have one movie and that's
the irishman and so our delete function
has worked
there we are so we've installed express
we're using express to build all of our
applications we have our app running on
port 3000 we are using express
to pass the json
effectively back and forth we have a
simple array that array is then being
used to create an api to pull the
details then we're being able to add a
movie and search for a movie filtering
against an id
and then
we can actually finally go ahead and
delete a movie
all this using express js
today we're going to be covering node.js
authentication using jwt or json web
tokens so let's get started so why are
we going to go down this path so let's
cover the key things that you need to be
asking yourself such as what is a json
web token
what is the value of using a json web
token and then what is the actual
structure of the jwt look like
and then let's go through some use cases
of where you'd actually use jwts uh both
in the enterprise and uh
in the real world
and then finally we're actually going to
go through a demo on how you can
actually install a jwt
using express and node.js
so let's dive into what actually is a
json web token
so a json web token is actually based on
an open standard it's one that you can
actually go ahead and research
and it allows a
definition of a compact self-contained
way of being able to securely transmit
information between parties using a json
object an adjacent object is a
javascript array and it's very compact
it's a very tight way of being able to
send data back and forth
the thing that's great about using a
json web token is that the information
itself is encrypted and it can only be
verified and trusted through a public
private key pair and we'll get into that
about how you can actually get to those
so you know why would you actually want
to go ahead and use a json web token are
there other formats that you can use
well yes there are other formats you can
use but what's great about jwt is that
it is a great way to be able to pass
data from http servers so if you're
building a web application and you have
a web location where you need to pass
authentication over using a jw2 is a
great way to be able to do that
so for instance you may have a number of
enterprise applications
that run across your cloud environment
you may have some enterprise
applications that run in your data
center and you want to have
people come in such as your employees or
customers authenticate once and then be
able to have their id transition from
one to the next jwt is a great way to do
that the content is extremely secure and
we'll get more into that in a moment but
it is the highest level of security you
can have right now
and the final great thing about working
with jwt is that the actual tokens
themselves are very well documented and
so there's actually a lot of passes that
you can use so being able to add in jwt
into your application is very very easy
to do which makes it very easy for you
to actually implement and a large scale
authentication and authorization and so
authorization is a key word there
that's something that you're probably
coming across um a lot instead of just
being able to identify who you are we
want to be able to authorize what you
have access to
so let's have a look at the structure of
a jwt there are several key elements um
the first is the header and that's
actually going to break down
what
kind of token it is by default it's
going to be a gwt token and what is the
signing algorithm so sha 512 is a very
complex and secure algorithm and
certainly the one that i would recommend
that you use uh you can even go higher
than that but um sha 512 is a great
place to start
and then you have the payload and the
payload is the information that's been
actually encrypted within the web token
and so in this instance we have a name
the admin time type
sub name um just really you can put
whatever kind of information you want in
there as long as it's applicable
to the
service that you're passing the data
into
and then you have your
signature which is
encoded header and payload with the
algorithm that you've sent so in this
instance it's sha 512 algorithm
so let's look at some of the use cases
that you'd have for jwt
so a couple of use cases would be
authorization so say for instance
you have a application and you want to
be able to authorize somebody to have
access to different parts of that
application
jwt is a great way to be able to encrypt
that data and be able to pass that data
back and forth
examples would be jumping from different
parts office 365 and be able to have
access to different features within the
system
and then another area would be if you're
doing information exchange so
information is being securely exchanged
from one person to another so a
blockchain scenario a multi-um
distributed environment where you want
to be able to have a way to be able to
securely transmit data back and forth
and know that that data is being
encrypted is another good example
so with that let's take a pivot and
we'll go ahead and we'll look at
creating a demo
using our standard stack of node.js and
we'll use express and postman um and
these are tools that you may already be
familiar with if you've seen other
videos that we've created in this series
and we'll go ahead and create
a jwt token
so let's go into our demo of how to
create a jwt
json web token there's gonna be some
tools that we need to get started with
the node.js is the first so let's go
ahead and find node.js at nodejs.org and
you can either download windows mac or
linux code
obviously you'd install the one that
would be for your operating system
the next tool that we want to install is
a those installed and up and running
so we're going to go ahead and let's
open up visual studio code
and we're going to start by creating our
project
let's go full screen on this get rid of
the welcome screen
and that's going to open up a folder
where we'll actually have our project
we're going to put this on our desktop
for right now let's go create a new
folder and we'll call this node jwt
[Music]
for json web token select that folder
and we're going to want to go ahead and
use npm to initialize
this folder for uh for node and so let's
get rid of the welcome screen again and
let's go ahead and one things i love
about
vs code is going to run the terminal
window right from in here so let's go
ahead and
select npm init
or already knows to pull from the folder
that we're in
and we're just going to select
yes here in a second
for our
yep let's go ahead and create that and
you'll see that the packet has been
created
and there is a json packet with just
default information about the npm
package that we created for node
and we're going to go ahead and create
an index.js file that's what we've been
pulling from the package
and the index.js files we're going to
actually rewrite all of our code and
what we want to do right now is install
express
and express is going to be used to
create the apis that we'll be able to
test our jwt
against and then we'll also want to
install
a
jwt
file so let's call this json web token
and from our terminal window we'll just
go ahead
and install both of those and do that by
typing npm install
save
and then we're gonna put express
and json web token
express and json web token
and we'll just go ahead and let those
install
only takes a moment for those to get
installed
all right we're up and running okay
so let's go ahead and start bringing in
some of our apps so we're going to
create
an express app
and we're going to use the
get http
header to
have everything and go from the we're
going to actually have everything
running on our localhost and we're going
to run everything off port 3000 we'll do
that in a moment here but we'll have
everything running off a sub
folder called api it's where our web
applications can be running from
and we'll put in a message that
hey there to show that everything's up
and running
okay
and
[Music]
save that
and say if you can do control plus s to
save your files
and as you can with a lot of windows
applications i would encourage you to do
that a lot so let's go ahead and open up
postman with no i'm going to go to our
web browser on this one
and open up postman
it takes a moment to run the first time
and it comes
and postman again is a tool for being
able to
manage api calls and
so you don't have to write a script
so here we are
and we can go in here
and we can
that's where we're going to write our
script but we have to
do a couple of things first let's let's
get everything running so we want to
listen on for port 3000 that's we're
going to run everything off of
and in the console log we'll actually
throw in a message to confirm that we
are running on
uh everything is up and running we'll
just say okay
uh server started on port 3000
again we're going to be running
everything off localhost so you'll be
able to see this
um and this is as you imagine just a
test environment so let's go down into
our console we'll run this script node
index.js to run the script it runs
really fast not a whole lot going on
there and we're having everything
running off the api files so let's go
and we'll type in under our get local
host
colon
3000
xl
api and we hit
the
there's lots of different http headers
um we can use we're gonna use get for
right now
send that
and
hey there welcome to the api service so
two weekly this is just an api we're
creating right now this is not jwc we'll
get into that right now
all right
so we want to be able to post data and
uh post is actually pushing data in so
we're gonna go into uh going to create a
login screens again again this is all
api so it's not real but uh look it
you get the point
and then construct a user
and let's go ahead and what we're doing
here is we're creating
a
an array
of a random user and that they can have
a name of id1 that they have the user is
going to have an id value which is one
um a
username value which is gonna be john
and an email value of john gmail.com
and then we'll make this
a
json
web token jwt signing
and they'll have to sign with their user
and
this is going to use a secret key which
will be our hash
our hash 512
token
and
respond to the json with the token
okay so let's see now
okay and we're going to
hamp dot and this will be our post
api
[Music]
posts
and what we're going to be able to do is
we're going to jump from one app to
another app and you'll be able to see
how we can move the token with it
and the message will read
post
created
all right
so let's just run that script
index.js
runs real quick
okay
so if we come over here and we go to
posts
and hit send
and say message posts created
good
so let's go ahead and try that again
and we want to go to the
login
so go from one app to another app select
post
and
here in the login
we should be able to
request the token
this will be our gwt token
and we hit send we should get our token
and here you can see the the whole token
is encrypted
it's that huge long line
it's very unique
and
now we want to be able to go in and say
okay
let's verify
the token so we've gone ahead and we've
created the token but now we need to as
we go from app to app we need to
actually verify the token so we're going
to get an error message if we don't
verify the token correctly
so i'm going to put in a function to
verify
the token
and
we're going to
create a bearer header
value
which will be
the headers and the authorization for
that
and if type of bearer header
i'm going to have it if it's not correct
it'll be undefined
otherwise
this back token
will be split
and we're going to require the token
for our baro token
else
sense status
403
okay so barotokin is what we're going to
be calling against
to verify our token i'll show you how
that works in just a moment
and this will be to authorize
and to authorize we'll need to actually
go ahead and
use the token so we can actually
put in here
all right so i think
everything's looking pretty good
oh and
if things if we get the error message
means that it's we'll see the the
message forbidden if we don't put in the
code correctly so let's
double check that everything is looking
good i'm going to verify that the token
is required
okay
so if it is then jwt dot verify
[Music]
and this will
connect our token appropriately
and we'll be able to
put that in as a part of our secret key
and if it is successful
and put in
that message there
and we're also going to play in the
authorization data
yep looking good
as you can see a lot of the work is just
making sure that everything is aligned
up correctly
okay so let's run our code nodeindex.js
there we go nice and fast
and
i'm going to go in and
localhost
api posts
and change this to post
so this one api which is the api posts
which is
up here
we'll hit send
and you can see that we have the error
code forbidden has come up which is what
we were expecting
because we haven't been able to put in a
secret key
and
put in the comment there
forbidden
as we're stepping through the code
but now what we can actually do is we
can go back and we can grab the token
and here is our token below
and we just want the token itself we
don't need the wrappers
and copy that
come over here
and if we write again it's going to say
forbidden but
if we go into
author into
our
headers
we can put in authorization
and then the value
we do bearer and then the key
and once we do this
we now get all of the data that we were
asking for pullback
which is exactly what we wanted
so you can see here how we can actually
securely
use a jwt to pass values back and forth
across the application
okay
and we hit
authorization we select that and approve
it yep we keep authorizing so if you
don't authorize and you don't get the
data
okay so we have everything against the
api and we have one application which is
called api post we have another
application called api plugin and we're
able to move the data back and forth
using
our secret key in our jwt
token
and we have everything running on port
3000 of our local host server
and that's our demo
so first of all let's cover why you'd
want to go through this tutorial so
we're going to cover what my sql is
we're also going to tell you how we're
going to connect with node.js and why
you'd want to do that with mysql and
then finally we're going to do a demo
taking you through all the steps on how
you can actually do that kind of
connection
so what is my sql well basically my
sequel is probably the world's most
popular relational database um so if you
think of relational databases that are
table driven mysql is arguably the most
popular
database out there for rdbs systems it
is by far the most popular open source
uh relational database
the entire database is written in c and
c plus plus it's been around for a
really long time and again it's open
source which is great
which means that there are no licenses
or costs for actually using my sequel
and you'll find that companies of all
sizes from small mom and pop shops all
the way up to massive enterprise global
enterprises are all using my sql so you
know why would you want to then take
that next step of connecting node.js
with mycool well fundamentally comes
down to the basics of the differences
between the two products
mysql is a database and node.js is a
architecture framework for building out
web applications now again with mysql
it's open source it's free to use you
don't have to pay anything there are no
licenses which if you compare it with
other solutions out there is a big deal
my sequel even though it is open source
is incredibly powerful it's one of the
more mature open source programs out
there i think apache is probably
arguably more apache web server it's
probably more mature but my sequel is
very close behind it so it has had a
huge amount of investment this is not a
solution that's only a couple years old
we're talking about a solution that's
more than 15 years old
very very structured very powerful and
you can do a lot of really good things
with it
um you can actually then
build solutions with it and using php
java really any kind of database um even
other systems and other frameworks will
allow you to interact with mysql
and
it just allows you to work with just
huge amounts of data very very quickly
so let's go through a demo of how you'd
actually use node.js and mysql
so i'm going to go ahead and we're going
to get started by putting our
environment together so let's start by
selecting node.js and downloading it so
we'll get to nodejs.org
and there you have your options for
windows mac or if you want to go for the
source code you can go ahead and
download and install that
next is to install zap and so i'm going
to go to
zap installers for a quick search and
it's on our apache friends.org site and
here we have example windows linux and
mac os 10.
and then finally we want to go ahead
and install visual studio so visual
studio is going to be our ide our
integrated development environment in
this instance we're going to use visual
studio code if you don't use visual
studio code
it's a great free open source solution
for being able to build applications
i'm a big fan of it so i encourage you
to use it
and go ahead and download install that
and we have visual studio um code up and
running so go ahead and we can open up a
new folder
and let's go ahead and create a new
folder and just put a stratified desktop
here and it's just for
kicks and giggles so i'm going to type
in node my sql for our source code and
open up that folder and select that
and so we now have this folder selected
in our visual studio code editor
and what we want to do is we want to
get rid of the welcome page and we don't
really need that anymore
and
we're going to terminal window so we're
going to see the
scripts that we're writing we're going
to be using tunnel quite a bit um in
this so for instance we're just going to
test that we have npm installed we do so
that's great
and we're going to go npm init and
that's actually going to set up our own
node package module and we can actually
see that the json file for the package
has been created
so we go in there we can see that all
the defaults are selected
now you'll see that index.js is the
default uh file that will be created so
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to create our own index.js file and
we're going to add in some instructions
into that file to actually install the
correct software from the mpn package
and the first thing you want to do is
install express
which is a package that's great for
building uh lightweight web applications
not mobile applications i suppose if
you're doing a responsive design
but in this it's really it's a web
application environment so we're going
to
put in
the requirements for that and then we're
going to also go and require that my sql
gets installed
and
you'll see that for both of them we're
just going to use npm's default commands
for creating it and we'll go down to the
terminal window and we'll do mpm install
and it's going to
install the express and my sql
environment
and as that installs you actually see on
the left hand side under uh the folder
you actually see
the files starting to be installed
so for instance we have the node modules
and underneath that will be all the
subsequent files that we need
and there we are everything is installed
all right so let's go ahead and validate
some of these clients make sure
everything is installed so we're going
to open up zamp which allows us to go in
and
view and see that everything's installed
so we have my sequencer we have a patch
installed
we can start and stop and the services
with zam go ahead and do that you can do
this through telewindow as well but
the
ui interface is really nice so let's go
into
my
sql and
interface
and you'll see that we don't have any
databases
these are all just
the standard test databases and so we
have to go ahead and create one
and so let's
get our
single database connection created
so we're going to write
const
db equals mysql
create connection
and we want to create connect to
the localhost in this instance
and user is just going to be a
root user account
which is the standard user account that
comes from my sql uh there is no
password for the root user when you're
running it locally or i encourage you to
change that as quickly as you can
because you don't really want to have a
password-free environment
and now we want to be able to then
connect to the mysql
environment
so do write db dot connect
uh parenthesis error and we want to
throw an error message if the connection
isn't good
so if we do error
we'll throw the
arrow message to the log window
and
if we don't
then we'll write mysql connected
all right
and then we want to connect that to our
express app
the next step we want to do after we
made our connection
is to go ahead and create a database so
we'll do both steps at the same one so
writing the script right now and then
we'll run the commands uh in the
terminal window so we can actually
create a database
and so we're going to go ahead and we
want to create
a database
and let's write let's sql equals
create
database
i'm going to call the database node
mysql you could call it whatever you
want um but this is just a node my sql
script
the db
query
sql
error
through error message
rest.send
database created
so we'll throw a message saying that
database has been created let's go save
that
to demonstrate that we've connected and
we created this so let's go ahead
and
do node index.js
to run that and connect it to my sql
that's great
good first step and then we'll go to
window
i will go to localhost
3000 which is
the default
connection but what you'll see is that
we've actually created the name of the
database has been changed to node by sql
so we've got an error message which we
expected and so what we're going to do
is we're actually going to go ahead
and
[Music]
we're going to say we want to listen
and if the error message if comes up to
3000
then
in the console window we want to
put a message of service started on
porsche 3000
so let's try that again
load index.js
yep and server has started for 3000
let me refresh that
i'm still getting an error message
and what we want to see is
let's go ahead and see how database
hasn't been created
so let's go and connect to
database
database
let's go ahead and click
create db
on port 3000 all right so by doing that
we write that command and that function
and that goes and creates our database
and we'll actually see
but we have now node mysql has been
created
great first start
now we have to go in and create some
tables we have no tables in there
all right so let's go down let's go
ahead and create a table
so what you're seeing right now is that
we're using
the index.js environment within a
package on node.js to actually create
and control everything that we want to
see
in our windows so all of the work that
we're doing for creating a table for
creating the database
for initializing the core files it's all
being done through js and so here we are
going to create a new table and call it
creating it's going to be called the
employee table
and so once we run the command create
employee is going to create table has
the employee fields which is going to
have an
id which will be an integer that will go
into auto increment they'll have a name
field
and we'll also put in a designation
field
and
[Music]
that will have a primary key as well
keep it very simple right now
and let's just
put our db connection so that everything
connects effectively
okay so
everything goes correctly then we'll
have the message employee table created
so let's test this out
and
note
index.js
make sure that the data we have now
actually a database field that we can
connect to so we've got node my sequel
so we're connecting to the correct
database obviously we get an error
and then we'll try that again
yeah okay database so database has a
name and because of it note mysql
there's no fields in there yet
so let's go ahead and
put in create employee fields and that's
run the function that creates the new
table
and then
voila
we have a new table
and so
the next action we want to do is
actually
populate the table with a record
so
this starts becoming familiar so we're
not going to
put in a a single record we'll call it
employee one for right now
and
we'll write the
the function
you know employee one and when we run
that function
uh he'll actually go ahead and
create the lig insert the record into my
sql
and then the name will be jake smith
and the designation
will be
a chief executive officer
certainly encourage you to put your own
self name your own name into this make
yourself your own ceo because why not
and we're going to make this as an
insert record
i'm going to insert into the employee
table
i'm just using some basic sql scripting
here
and what you'll see actually with
visual studio code is that
it's actually providing a lot of prompts
to make it easier to write your code
microsoft is looking to actually add
some ai
to visual studio code to actually start
auto completing
script which will make it even easier
to write your code
all right so let's go run node index.js
received i've been connected and we'll
grab the
function employee one
and let's go over to our express site
let's just go and we'll insert the
command employee e1
employee has been added and we will just
validate this by going back to my sql
and we'll refresh it and you'll see we
click on the employee tables we should
now have an employee in there yep there
we go jake smith
hold on jake
first record
all right so we'll be able to now select
the employee
so let's go ahead and do that
and we want to be able to easily get the
employee list
so let's use our sql command
and
do select
star which is everything
from the employee table so we're
actually playing everything from the
employee table
i'm going to query the database
let's throw a message to confirm that
the query is successful
we'll put everything in the console log
results
all right let's give this a whirl
okay so
let's go and run our command
or localhost 3000
but get employee
and it says employee details fetch now
we go to the console window in visual
studio yep there we go we have now all
the packet information including the id
about jake smith
okay so let's go ahead and see if we can
actually update the employee information
so as you can see now we're starting to
run into just our standard sql commands
and so we want to
be able to update the employee from a
browser
and as you can tell we're not using any
forms or any other types of records
we're just simply interacting
with between the
the browser the server and
the database
and the new name will be updated name
record
i will show that we're matching against
id1
all right so that's wrong
[Music]
and
[Music]
jake smith is there
now go
and select
jason
slash one
we've now gone ahead and updated
the object
uh jigsmith information
so let's click on complete table
and we now see he says updated name i
know not very creative but
it allows you to see a change
and finally we can go ahead and delete
the record as well
so it's going to be similar to
update but i'm deleting instead
going to delete
the record from the employee table
[Music]
and
[Music]
and then we want to be able to
show that the record has been
deleted
okay
[Music]
deleted and we go to uh
database mean that gc
from the employee table
that there are no entries
the one record that was there has been
deleted
and so this shows you how you can very
easily control everything
from
using your connection into mysql
right from node package manager
you can create a table
you can select your records
you can then
update
any record that you
selected and finally you can delete any
record that
you want to be able to delete
so what we're going to do is so what's
in it for you so in this uh presentation
we're going to go through three key
things you know what is mongodb
how do you connect to mongodb with
node.js
and mongodb is part of the mern stack so
we're going to cover what the mer stack
is and how it applies to node.js
so what is mongodb so mongodb is a it's
a
probably the most popular
nosql database out there it's
cross-platform and
very easy to scale it's available on all
cloud systems you can also run it
locally which is what we'll be doing
later on in our demo
but it's just a very flexible database
environment for modern uh applications
it works on the concept of collection
and documents
um what you'll find is uh
mongodb was originally written in c plus
plus and it is what's referred to as a
nosql database so this is different to a
relational database which is built up of
tables with rows and columns this is a
nosql database as simply a lot faster
and more powerful for the work that
you're doing
and you're able to use mongodb very easy
you can actually go ahead and download
it we'll actually do that as part of our
demo
so you know why connect node.js with
mongodb
well the reason why you want to do this
is that mongodb is a modern database
it's not
restricted by the the challenges of
scalability that all the relational
databases have
it's really designed for building mobile
applications and websites that scale
into the millions and millions of users
so mongodb probably the most important
feature is scalability
the performance of the database is
phenomenal
and it is extremely highly available for
the solutions that you'll be creating so
when you push it out your solution to
the cloud you almost guarantee it's
always going to be running
you also have the ability to be able to
scale to very large complex
multi-site solutions in fact one of the
very first mongodb applications i built
was a multi-tenant environment and it
just worked really well
and you'll be able to easily deploy your
solutions across microsoft azure aws
google cloud uh et cetera so you know
why do you want to keep connecting to
mongodb and i think probably um one of
the other areas that's probably
is often forgotten with [ __ ] it's just
the concept around big data and you can
i mean when you talk about big data
you're talking about absolutely massive
massive databases and
mongodb is front and center for all of
that
you can do your effective content
management and delivery
um it has an effective mobile and social
infrastructure so um by that it allows
you to be able to build out solutions
that can go to all modern day types of
applications and the data is actually
very easy to manage
through your central data hub
and then finally being able to connect
to mongodb is very easy um particularly
as there is a client called mongoose
that makes the connections extremely
easy so you're finally um let's kind of
look into how [ __ ] db is part of the
mer stag
so learnstack is a javascript stack and
it's of javascript solutions that are
built for modern single page
applications and there are four key
solutions in the merge stack there's
mongodb which is your database
express which is your server side uh
http environment react which is the
solution for being able to
create your solutions on the client and
the node.js
which actually manages the whole
environment it's really an environment
that's designed to make it very easy to
be able to build out modern day
solutions so mongodb is the m in moon
express is the e
react is the r
and node
js is the n so again
as you start working with some of our
other videos that we have um here you'll
be able to see how all of these tools
really complement each other so we've
done an introduction on
mongodb
really the best thing now is to get you
out you know your hands dirty by
actually doing a demo so we're going to
go through a demo what i would strongly
encourage you however though is that
this demo really does build on a lot of
the other videos that we've done in this
series
so
you really do want to spend some time on
the node.js video the node.js for
express video the node.js for apis video
i really all those videos help
complement the work that you'll be doing
with this video here you'll see some
real strong correlations plus a lot of
new content as well so with that we're
going to jump into the demo
so let's do our demonstration on how to
use mongodb with node.js
first thing we want to do
is go ahead and install node.js so
you're going to go and do google search
node.js and that should bring up a
result of going to nodejs.org
and here you can download node.js for
multiple platforms
so windows linux
mac os they're all supported you can
also get the original source code and
recompile your version of node.js if you
want to
now we're just going to install the
windows version
and the next thing you want to do is
install your favorite
text editor i'm going to install visual
studio code vs code
it runs on all leading platforms mac os
windows and linux it is open source you
can edit it and i like it because you
can do an awful lot with it
just a lot of extensions and it's just a
great tool all around
so that's the next thing you want to
install
and then we want to go ahead and we want
to go to
mongodb.com so we can install the
mongodb database
so you want to go to software
community server
and you want to then select
the
mongodb community server
uh which platform you want
and where it's going to connect with
and you want to select the
download to install that
and that'll take a moment or two for you
to download and get that up and running
once you've done that we want to go
ahead and we're going to open up vs code
so we can start editing and the code
that we need for our new solution
so let's go ahead and create a folder uh
off our desktop that will use for
mongodb so i already have a folder
created called demo i'm just gonna
select that and then inside there i'm
gonna to put in a node
mongodb
and select that folder
and that's going to open up vs code and
it's going to have our folder in here so
we're going to get rid of the welcome
screen we don't need that
um we do want to however open up our
terminal window so we're going to uh run
that that's one of the things that i
really like about vs code is you can
actually have your terminal window or
command line window actually inside the
development environment you're working
at so you don't have to be jumping from
one solution to another and then we're
going to initialize our package so npm
in it for the folder that we're in it's
going to create our
node package manager is going to create
our default package and we're going to
hit return that's going to go ahead and
start the process
and we're just going to go with the
default
um
settings
that npm is going to give so just hit
return return return a few times and
that will get up and running for you
and our entry point for the application
is going to be index.js
area that's uh
gs package and there we have everything
this is just the
uh the the json package that provides
the instructions that npm would use to
pass the um the program now you notice
that we have index.js as our
leading file so we actually have to add
a new file here and we're just going to
tour this one
index.js so
we actually have a file that can be
referenced
and now we're going to go ahead and
we're going to actually put in
our
default application so express is going
to be required so we're going to make
sure that that
is included in our first line of our
instructions
then we're also going to
have a path that's required
and
we're going to require handlebars
and these are all part of our express
environment
and don't forget to save your file as
you're going along
and we're also going to have
express
phbs
and this is going to be our express
handlebars
and we're all going to
allow
insecure
prototype
access
you wouldn't normally do this but uh
because we're running everything locally
it just makes it easier for
you to actually get all the code in
and then we're also going to add in
our body parser
and these are all the required solutions
that we need
to be installed
when you're running this
package
and so let's save the file and then
let's go ahead and run it so we're going
to do npm
install
and we do
save and this will install express
and we're also going to have install
path
uh handlebars
uh express handlebars
[Music]
and this is where we'll install
prototyping
and we'll also have
the body parser
[Music]
installed and we're just going to run
that
this will just take a moment or two to
install
all right there we go
so we have everything installed which
allows us to now start working with our
scripts
so we're going to create an app in
express
and we're going to listen on port 3000
and
we're going to have a message then go to
our console log
and we have everything running off our
local port on local host on port 3000 so
let's go and we're going to select node
index.js
and shows us everything's running
which is good you can actually test this
in our web browser if we wanted to
okay so let's start working on our app
so our app is going to
use bodyparser
and we're going to encode
our request
and the goal here is we're going to
create a file that's going to go back
and forth
to
mongoose among to mongodb
so body parts is going to use json to
encrypt
the content
and we're going to do a get command to
get our results
and if we worked if you've seen the api
video then we did that here in fact it's
probably a good idea to actually sit
down and look through some of the other
videos that we've created such as the
json
sorry the node.js node.js
for express node.js
for apis and node.js for authentication
before doing this video
we're going to
create a default page and it's going to
say welcome to the students database
the principles that we're putting down
here you'll be able to apply to any
solution that you're creating with
mongodb
and so we want to have
a simple action that we're going to
put on here which is going to be
click to gain access
okay
we're going to put in the path and way
to get the list from
okay
all right
so here is our basic web page that we're
creating
nothing fancy
but it's going to take you to a place
where you can actually get all the
content now what we're going to do is
we're actually going to go and pull the
content from manga
so run this and open up web browser
you'll see what it looks like let's just
go to localhost
close out these
other tabs don't need them localhost
3000
and there we see welcome to the student
database click on the database and you
click on if we click on it now nothing
will happen so yeah nothing there
so let's make something happen
okay
all right so
let's begin extending our app so what
we're going to do is we want to
set
the views
and we'll do a
join
on our directory name
and app
engine
so let's go for our views we haven't
have engine yet but let's go ahead and
create a new folder
i'm going to call that one views
and let's expand that
actually that should be okay
hps
express handlebars
and we're going to allow prototype
access for express enterprise
so with express handlebars if this is
new to you it allows you to separate
your content from your layout
which if you have developed with
swift for a mobile application
on the mac using xcode is the same
principle there but for
a web application
so we're just i'm putting out here
some of our
default environment
settings
i'm going to set our view engine
for handlebars
there we are just checking through our
code it's looking good
okay so that provides
that so let's create a new folder under
our views and this one we're going to
call layouts so again this is where we
are splitting our layouts
and we're going to have
a folder called models at the root of
our application and under models we're
going to put in
db.js so the dbjs file
is going to be where we put our
instructions
for our database and so here we're going
to go ahead and we're going to
require to import mongoose a mongoose is
a tool
in node.js that allows you to connect
to mongodb
so we're going to require the use of
mongoose and so we're going to do npm
install dash say save mongoose
and that's going to run and install our
local machine so we can actually test
this out
and once we've got this installed what
we're going to do is we're going to
start connecting to a database that
we're going to call student db
okay we're already already installed so
let's go mongoose.connect
and
we're going to call it mongodb
and we're going to run this off our
local host
so we installed the uh community version
that has just run out of our localhost
and it's going to run from the port
27017
and we're going to call this one
studentdb
so again with our application we're
splitting out
all the functionality so if you want to
reuse elements you can
so we're going to have a new usernurl
parser
and we'll make sure we capture
everything correctly
okay
so if arrow then we'll
send a message to the console log
and we have either connection successful
or things go wrong
error in connection
and then if there is an error then what
we'll do is we'll have the error message
posted
okay
and then we're going to do require
[Music]
student
dot
model
so this will actually call the the model
we're going to create
and so what we need to do now is
creating
under models we're going to create
student.model
dot js
and this is where we're going to do
our instructions for
our student model so first thing we want
to do is we want to import
mongoose
express and the student model
so we've got our let's make sure we have
everything let's capture that
so let's go up to
our student model
all right so let's make sure that we
have everything so we want to have
mongoose
and
[Music]
i'm going to create a new variable
called student schema this will allow us
to structure
what our model will look like this will
be a
a new
new schema
in using mongoose
and our new schemer is going to be full
name
and we're going to break down
our
jsons package so
we're going to put in the instructions
for what
the schema would look like so
we have the type we have been required
this field is required
and
the second value is going to be email
type string
this field is required
that's the
message error message you want to send
if
the field isn't filled out
mobile phone number this will be just a
number
and
we're gonna have city
and this subtype will be
let's just make this a string we're just
gonna try and keep this simple for right
now
yeah this field is required
all right so here's our schema
looking pretty good
all right mongoose
dot model
and connect this to our
student model
so we want to go ahead and save that
okay
okay a new folder and this new folder is
going to be called controllers
and we have a new file under controllers
and that new file is going to be called
studentcontroller.js
let's go in and
see what we're going to add here
so we want to import
make sure we're running express
so express is required for our
controller
we also want to set up a variable for
router
so writer express.router
and we want to make sure we're also
connecting with mongoose
so we have a connection to our mongodb
and
we also want to make sure that we have
connection to our student model
so mungus mongoose dot model
and our student model
and this allows us to make sure that we
have
this student model
pulled over
effectively for our controller for our
student controller
okay so let's go to router
get
i'm going to render this
and student slash add or edit
we'll come into that in just a moment
so we want to be able to
view title and this will pull in
the insert
student
i'm going to use
under our views
we're going to create a new folder
and this one's going to be called
student
and we're going to create a new file and
this one will be
add or edit
dot js oh hps sorry for our handlebar
so you notice we don't have to put the
file extension
uh no js manages all that for us
so
router dodge post
so this will be
are we're going to get our content and
then we're also going to post content so
the post will go back
as part of our body
and there'll be an id
so we want to then instead insert the
record that we'll be creating
so again if you've been if you've worked
through the nodejs api
video
then you'll start seeing that there's
some commonalities here of being able to
insert or update a record
and we actually cover that
using just a sample json package this
really takes you to that next level
okay
okay so we want to put in a new student
record and this will be student
and we're going to have that full name
is going to
come from our body
and we're going to also capture
the email
essentially we're going to follow the
model that we created
and our mobile phone
finally with a student city
[Music]
and then we want to save the record that
we create
okay
all right so we're going to manage our
error message
and we're going to put in
similar messages that we've put in
before
so we want to redirect to our student
list
and we're going to go ahead and create
that in a moment
so
let's create a new file student list.hbs
so list.hbs
and here
so what we do is with tuned list that's
actually going to match then
the
controls for being able to
display the records in the database
and then we'll put
a message if there's an error then you
know we'll put an error message there
and ask you to report the error message
we're going to try and not do that
all right so
now the next step we need to go through
is going to call a function to update
the record
and let's go ahead and we're going to
update that records
and we do the student.find1 and update
command
okay
okay so we will redirect to our student
list as needed if not we'll throw an
error message to our console log
yeah
looking good
and again this is just an example
but uh something that you'll be able to
do yourself
i have with it your own solution
and
then we want to like go back to our list
to
then render
the records
all right
and here we want to put student and then
how we're going to find the record
and
we'll throw a error message to our
console log
so as you can see we always throw an
error message to the console load
error messages are really useful
okay
all right looks good
save that
okay let's do another router and this is
two
we're going to do the router against id
so allow us to
get the content
so i'll be able to get the information
by id of the student
what you can see is there's a lot of
the work we're doing here
is very repetitive
um and
you'll find as you create more modular
code that it makes easier for you to
write your code and update and manage
your code
okay so we're going to
get out view title we're going to put
them into our document
okay
all right
so our next router
is
we want to be able to delete
our record by id
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to find our records for our year
record we just find it by id
and then we'll do find by find id and
remove
okay so we're gonna
to once we've removed your record we're
gonna redirect to our list so we can
show our student list
and otherwise we'll send an error
message to our console log
okay
so i think we have what we need
maybe there's maybe there's one more
thing i think we need to
i think this is good
okay
so
let's go to our
layouts add a new file there
we're going to call this one main layout
dot hbs
and here we're going to put the skeleton
of
our web page together
let's
write this out so we put in
html
code
and
[Music]
we're just going to keep this real
simple
header
we want a title
this is going to be students
database
and i mean we just got students
so
we now go to
[Music]
we're going to try and find out
bootstrap for we're going to just grab
that
and we're going to use
bootstrap to get started
and there are a couple of components
there's a css component and then there's
the javascript component so let's just
go copy the
css component
and then we're going to just link that
into the header section of our
web page
so
and then
here's an example of different
components you can create
uh if you're not used if you haven't
used bootstrap before it's an open
source framework originally developed by
twitter great tool
so
in our header
we want to
put in the link to the css
there's that
and
now i need to also
in our own styles
so we've got here some styles that we
created earlier on
um for
the work that we're doing you can just
paste those in
so we have a box style that we want to
use that will extend the box style that
you get
with bootstrap
all right so we're going to start
working on our body content
plus
bg info and so this is actually bg info
is
a css class file from bootstrap that you
can use
and you have the id of box
and again we're going to do
another class
which allows us for our table structure
so a little bit of knowledge of
bootstrap is great here
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to put in
the content which we're going to call
body and this will
show up on the screen
so again we're pulling from records
within bootstrap dig through bootstraps
lots of content there for you to be able
to take advantage of
okay
so now we want to be able to add or edit
our record
view title
and the
um
the
the the french brackets allow you to be
able to pull records and content
directly from
the code that we're writing
so we're pulling title from insert
record and it's part of our
router
command
and then we'll put in our form
actually student
post
i'm just gonna do a basic form here
nothing fancy
hmm we will put in the first
record will be a hidden field and this
will be for id
so we want to want to generate the id we
don't want to have somebody put that in
and then we will put in
our
form elements
so we'll have first will be
a label
it'll be full name
be
an input field
this will be text in the input field
and
again we're using form dash control
which is from
bootstrap css
and we'll have
a full name
and placeholder before name so
where we have name there
will actually match up
with
the value that we're putting in our
model
so here we have student full name
so we're matching everything up to the
model that we created
okay so let's do this for
our
remaining form elements
and again as you see we can put this
together really quickly
so i'm going to put in full as well the
email
and then we'll do
mobile
and city
and
here we keep going
and form group
yeah we'll be able to have the
type of
tool for putting in mobile
so as you can see because we're using
just standard html here you can actually
reference external libraries such as
uh javascript libraries for
formatting the field that you're in
regular expressions things like that
and let's put in our final value
which will be for city
and normally when i'd be writing this
by hand i would actually be copying
pasting
sections of code and just changing the
values as necessary
just to make it easier on myself but
here i'm just typing out everything for
you so you can
see the
whole process
okay
all right so there are our values
of course remember save your files as
you're going along
everything looks good
and we're matching up our values
with our
records
and we want to have a button that allows
you to submit
you also want to have a button to select
view or if you want to be able to view
all the records
okay
looking good
okay let's go back over to list now we
want to be able to
pull our records so
this will display
the
list of students
in a table
right
let's go ahead and format that table
so we're going to put together our
format here but then we're also going to
add buttons at the bottom so we can
actually add a record to the database or
if we want to edit or delete a
particular record from the database
i'm going to call this one
a new student record
for student list
i'm just going to type all this in for
you
and you'll see how we put placeholders
for the values as we put them in
these are our table headers
okay
body content
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to add in
[Music]
an element that allows you to create
a row for each item listed
so if you have two or more items they'll
appear
as an individual row
on here
and again what we're doing is we're
pulling in the values to be able to
pull from the model that we created
earlier on
so this being the data that's been
submitted so we have it put in the value
for the email full name
and
mobile and city
we're not going to show id
so it's pulling out all of this data
that we created earlier on
so we have everything posted into our
list
as documents
so let's go into our hps file
and it's our list
let's bring our
file entry here
[Music]
this will be for city
then
this is just a placeholder
at the end
of the list
oh yeah you know what we're going to do
is we're going to add in
reference for the id
so we want to edit the document we can
and then we want to do the same thing if
we want to
delete the document
so hraf
course
student
and then
just delete
now delete based on the id
there we go
passing that instruction over
[Music]
simple
i'm going to ask him are you sure you
want to
delete if somebody clicks on the record
they hit cancel then it might get
deleted if they hit okay then it will
get deleted
what you can actually write
js in line
okay
and
then we want to
close out where
the row will end so how
each opens and closes
the record
just tying up some of the html there
save that
okay looking good
back to our root index file
so
see now
we want to
also require
our model
and then
we'll have our
student controller
also be
a require
of where it's going to pull the student
controller from
okay
and
this is just the instructions on where
we can actually find
the content
okay it looks good so let's do
node next js
everything's safe we're going to rerun
everything
and
we got an error
let's go check out where our error came
from
so let's go in to our files
this is one that we created
so
error is in
stream controller see where's the error
oh we need to
have our module we need to export our
module to our
router right let's go open up [ __ ]
database
and we can just start
seeing where the records are
it's just installing the latest updates
here
so
we need to go ahead and in our
connection string so it's on localhost
that's the port
let's just double check that make sure
we're
completely aligned so here's our
database connection
and
there's our port and student database
and we did this with one go to mongoose
for connecting to [ __ ]
so i'm going to connect
and here are where our records are being
stored
so we're going to create a database and
we're going to call this database
it's going to be called studentdb
db sbk sensitive
and collection name is
students
let's go ahead and create a database so
there yeah there's our database
and
let's go we run our index js file
and everything was successful
this is good
all right
so everything should have passed
successfully good good good
database connection is good
so let's go to localhost
and
here we are so we can start actually
navigating through our application
so we see we have our setup we have no
records
so let's go ahead and create one
and
we go through you can actually start
stepping through the different layouts
that you've created so here's our layers
separate
to our
code
so there's some spacing we probably need
to add that let's go ahead and just add
that
and
let's rerun our code
this is the fun bits where you know
everything is
just tidying up okay so you know
it puts in one line one space because we
didn't put in the actual html code for
creating multiple spaces
so we're going to go in and select
insert so let's put in
uh smith
and we'll do smith at
gmail.com
[Music]
and let's just put in a random
phone number
there we go we don't have any formatting
so we can put anything in there
and the city uh i know where am i um
this i'm in delhi so submit that
hit submit and it takes us to a list and
voila
we actually have a list with a record in
and if we go back to our database we can
actually refresh it and now we actually
start seeing our records being created
and we see the id is automatically
created and there's our records
okay let's go back
and now we can select edit we can edit
the record
so let's change our city to
bangalore hit submit
all right city is now bangalore
and if we want to we can
add it again
and so this is
pulling in
yeah if we do a delete it's going to
ask us do we really want to delete
okay
a little bit of formatting applying
there
and the records are all good so we can't
make that smith jones
but because you need to hit submit you
wouldn't update the record
so we hit submit updates the record
we hit delete it's going to say are you
sure we say yes we are
and
ah
it has
congrats that record okay so let's go
back to my code
and
because we have everything separated and
actually now just go to
our student controller
and we'll find our delete
you guys delete and we had a
you had a couple of minor errors there
it's where it's good to test out your
code
okay let's run that again
and
refresh everything
so we'll go to our database we're gonna
go create a new entry
let's call this one some john john
gmail.com
and we'll put in a phone number
you see that the formatting is just
playing from
um
[Music]
our uh bootstrap so there we are there's
john do you want to delete they say yes
yeah easy there we go all solved
and we hit refresh the record should be
gone yep it is
and so we've created an application
where we can update applications
we can create an application we can list
all the items and we did all of this
using uh just open source solutions
through node.js and that was with using
express some of the components come with
express
mongodb for our database and then
mongoose to connect to our database
so let's get started with typescript
with node.js but before we begin make
sure you have subscribed to our youtube
channel and click on the bell icon so
you never miss an update from simply
learn
so we'll first look at what is
typescript
typescript is an object-oriented and
strongly typed programming language
which is a superset of javascript
typescript was designed by anders
hegelsberg at microsoft
the limitations of javascript for
developing large-scale applications at
microsoft and among its external
customers led to the creation of
typescript
due to the difficulty of working with
complicated javascript code there was a
demand for custom tooling to make
development of javascript components
easier
typescript code is converted to
javascript which can be executed
anywhere javascript is supported in a
browser on node.js or any other
application
typescript is a javascript with some
additional features to support a more
robust interaction with your editor
typescript adds additional syntax to
javascript
typescript is a scripting language that
understands javascript and uses type
inference to provide powerful
capabilities with additional code
what is node.js
node.js is an open source server-side
execution platform for javascript code
node.js is a javascript runtime based on
the version 8 javascript engine from
chrome
node is an asynchronous event-driven
javascript runtime for building scalable
network applications
although node.js is excellent for
developing server-side apps it lacks
several current features such as type
checking it can also be difficult to
manage a node.js code base
node is commonly used for real time
applications like chat
news feeds and web push notifications
because it allows for a persistent
connection from the browser to the
server
the current coding method such as static
typing and type checking are supported
by typescript
it's designed to create complex and high
level applications that's why having
typescript as a primary language for
supporting node.js capabilities would be
idle
this also allows us to develop server
side apps with rigorous type checking
avoiding run type errors and other
typescript benefits while maximizing
node.js capabilities
now let us see how to set up the
development environment for typescript
with node.js
the prerequisites are we need to have
typescript installed in our device and
node.js
to install node.js go to the official
website
go to nodejs.org and go to downloads
so here you can see
we have node.js for different browsers
for windows mac os
and source code
so go to windows if you have windows pc
and click on install
click on windows and here you can see it
is getting installed since i have
already installed in my device i'll
cancel it
so once you have installed go to the
command prompt
and just enter
node.v to check if node is installed
properly
so here you can see the node is
installed in my
system
to install typescript just run the
command npm
node package manager
install
globally
typescript
run this command and typescript will be
installed since i have already installed
typescript in my device
cancel this so once you have installed
typescript to check if typescript is
installed or not to see if the compiler
is installed just run the command
typescript compiler space
version
here you can see it will show the
version of typescript compiler
so now that we have installed both
typescript and
node.js let's see
our example program for typescript with
node.js
so let's jump into visual studio code
one more prerequisite is we need to have
visual studio code installed
so create a new folder and create a new
project
so we'll run an example program we'll
create a function
we'll write a program to add two numbers
so sum
number one
comma number two
will return number one and number two
console.log
we'll call the function sum
and we'll provide the arguments
so we'll provide the value
9 comma
5
so let's save
and run this program
first we'll run
typescript.cmd
type.ts command
then we'll enter
then we'll run node and the file name
here you can see
it's showing the value showing the
output as fourteen nine plus five the
sum of nine plus five is forty so we'll
delete this
and
write another program
to show a hello message or a welcome
message
so we'll create a function
we'll name the function as welcome
and will return
that user
is equal to
simply learn
console log
we'll call the function
welcome
and pass
so here we go we'll save this and check
whether we have an error
so here we go showing welcome to simply
learn we're going to be going through
some of the simple questions that you
would be asked during a node.js
interview let's just get started
so the first question you're probably
going to be asked is you know you know
what is node.js you know do you know
what it's for and essentially node.js is
one of the most popular if not the most
popular uh open source cross-platform
javascript programs and it allows you to
build out web applications that run on
the server it's extremely flexible it
allows you to implement a lot of
solutions outside of just the core
programming runtime and allows you to
build solutions extremely quickly in an
open source mindset for devops
it is used essentially for creating
client size web applications
we'll see this later on and you may want
to talk a little bit about
using express.js and how you can build
out apis
to work with node.js and connecting to
databases such as mongodb
and that is also really good for being
able to store um data intensive
applications that are asynchronous and
event driven in their model
and this is important when you're
talking about
creating applications that can scale
rapidly
so you're gonna then ask be asking how
does nodejs work well node.js itself is
actually built on the v8 engine and the
v8 javascript engine is the same engine
that runs javascript in your chrome web
browser extremely fast
it allows for um high output and
non-blocking out through your i o input
outputs and is a single threaded event
loop
so you're going to be then asked you
know where can you use node.js and and
the reality is the applications for
node.js keep expanding but there are
some core applications that you can work
with node.js right now so such as web
applications distributed system and
network applications
probably referencing the web
applications is a really good starting
point because here you can actually talk
about maybe some examples that you've
done where you're building out some of
these web applications uh indeed one of
the things that you want to be
consistently doing and peppering your
answers with is examples of work that
you have done now it doesn't matter if
those examples are purely experimental
or
training examples that you've done the
fact that you've actually worked with
node.js and created a distributed system
or a web application is really valuable
because it shows that the person that
you're meeting with that you have
knowledge and understanding and
practical experience of applying the
theory of working with no js with the
practice of working with node.js
so be asked about you know your
essentially the io
refers to the transfer of data in and
out of a system and that's really it you
know there's a reason why google calls
their conference io it's the transfer of
data in and out of our brains at that
conference the application is same here
it's about moving data in and out of
systems through using node.js
and that every um event can be tracked
and whether it's on a physical device or
network or files within a system again
it's input and output
so let's go through and you know you're
going to be asked can you explain the
difference between front end and back
end development and this is a question
that i get asked a lot when i'm meeting
with clients um you know people get
really confused about what is the
difference between front-end and
back-end development bottom line
front-end is what gets resolved inside
of your web browser or the app on your
mobile device back-end is what gets
resolved
essentially um what we call the the back
office or server side applications but
that's becoming more and more synonymous
for what gets run in the cloud
so web applications um really get a lot
of the functionality of web application
gets run in the front end anything with
css html5 uh client-side javascript it's
all going to get run on the front end
everything else such as connecting to a
database um gets run behind the scenes
in the back end
and so you know anything that's going to
have like graphics is going to be on the
front end uh apis are going to be run on
the back end and then just finally some
of the scripting languages are used on
on the front end
so html css javascript those are all
common
core scripting languages that you would
use
you can use frameworks such as angularjs
and react.js or vue
those would be a front-end frameworks
backend frameworks will include java php
python and node.js are some of the
backend technologies you'd also
throw in there
net as well i mean it's just the whole
you know litany of front-end and
back-end technologies and frameworks
that you can use and this is actually a
good point to kind of explain the
experience you have outside of just
working with node.js but other
technologies that you've been working
with that potentially that the client is
also using
so another question you're going to be
asked when you're looking at node.js is
you know can you tell me about npm and
so when somebody asks you what is npm
the first thing you can respond is do
you mean node package manager and the
reason why you want to respond like that
is that you want to qualify that
question with understanding that you
know what they're talking about but you
want them to verify that and so node
packet manager is npm
and it's responsible for packaging all
of your modules that you're working with
in node.js and we have a whole series of
videos that we've done on node.js and
every single one of them
includes references to mpm
so you're going to be asking you know so
okay you've told me um what it is you
know can you go into a little bit more
um details you know can you provide two
main functionalities and so one of them
is being able to
manage online repositories of modules
and packages um so you can go to like
search.nodejs.org
and you can find a packages that you can
install into your solution
such as expressjs
and it also provides a command line
utility that allows you to manage
your packages very quickly through
terminal window or command line
i use vs code a lot visual studio code
and it has a command line utility built
right into it that allows me to interact
with npm
so what are some of the modules in
node.js and so you know modules
in node.js they're essentially like
javascript libraries so you can think of
some of the javascript libraries that
you may have used the functionality is
somewhat the same but they're designed
for node.js and to run on the server and
there are ways in which you can go ahead
and create some of those modules so for
instance
if we're creating a web server you can
actually use the require commands to be
able to require that the server be there
so the example we have on the right hand
side
shows that we really do need to have
http which is a web server and we
require that to be installed and so that
if you're running that
npm package it will actually install the
http server and then you actually write
some code to actually then listen on the
local host port 2000 for where you'll be
running your application
and there are just you know there's a
whole bunch of modules that come
with node.js right out of the gate and
here are some of the modules that you
have and we also referenced just earlier
on http is a core module for
running a a web server
you have a utility function that is
useful for developers to
assess and features within your node.js
project you have a url
module for any url passing you'd be
doing
and you also have a stream which allows
you to be able to stream data in and out
of your system and be able to manage how
that's being worked and then zlib which
allows you to compress and decompress
files so that you can keep
your storage of files
to a minimum
so a question you're going to be asked
is you know why is node.js being
preferred over back-end technologies
such as java and php and particularly
java it's a very mature stable language
it's been around for more than 20 years
you know php
runs some of them the
most powerful and largest websites out
there such as facebook so why would you
use node.js well the first response is
kind of a gimme but it is really fast
and if you watched any of the videos
that we've done on node.js
building out solutions and developing
the solutions you'll see just how fast
it is
the second is the
really kind of the secret source with
node.js is the node packet manager and
no package manager allows you to install
additional functionality such as express
or [ __ ] as a database into your
solution
really quickly and there's over 50 000
bundles available for node package
manager
if you're building out a
real-time application that's data
intensive and you need to have apis
quickly developed then node.js is
another great it's really the great
solution for you it allows you to build
out these solutions really quickly
and there is a easy synchronization
between the server and the client due to
the code base
and then finally because the structure
of node.js is javascript if you are
making the pivot from being a front-end
web developer to node.js it's just going
to make it a lot easier for you to pick
up node.js because you have that common
language of javascript
and on top of that javascript is the
world's most popular
scripting language
so let's talk about some of the
differences between angular and node.js
and so the reason why this question may
come up is the person interviewing you
is seeing whether or not you do know the
difference between a front-end
framework and a back-end framework and
this is one of those questions where you
can go well
there are differences but the
differences are because they complement
each other
so angular is a front-end development
framework whereas node.js is a
server-side in framework other
differences though between the actual
frameworks themselves is that angular is
written in typescript which is a
modification of javascript node.js is
written in c and c plus
angular is used for building out single
page client-side web applications and so
that's a key word there is client-side
whereas node.js is about building out
fast and scalable server-side network
applications and so
again the two complement each other
angular splits web applications into the
mvc and model view control components
whereas node.js generates a lot of
database grades it does more than that
as well but you can think of node.js as
that glue to your database
so let's talk a little bit about when
you're connecting to a database with
node.js and so um you're going to
probably be asking what is um
the most popular database used with
node.js and there are a couple um
mongodb is largely the most popular
nosql cross-platform database
mysql is also very popular and that's a
more traditional relational database
um you would go with mongodb for really
more modern solutions when you're
looking at creating an application
that's going to really scale into just
managing masses and masses
of data that has to be
created read updated and deleted very
very quickly
for
some of the other popular libraries that
you use for node.js express.js is a very
popular one i really like working with
express.js allows me to build out web
applications really quickly uh more
importantly it allows me to build out
apis very quickly and which you know
apis are essentially web applications
themselves but being able to do that
very quickly with a framework like
express.js is very useful
mongoose is an application that makes
connecting to a [ __ ] database really
easy so
here is an example of express.js which
is a in itself really a flexible budge a
solution that you can do lots with and
mongoose which is a more
focused solution
which allows you know to you make it
easier to connect to your databases
so you know what are the pros and cons
of working with node.js there's lots of
ways we explained this earlier on that
you can actually build out
applications that run on the cloud why
would you you know what are the pros and
cons so a pro is that uh node.js is
extremely fast a processing an
event-based model uh it really is fast a
con is if you have something that is a
very heavy computational task it's not
so good at that um now i will caveat
that this is that node.js is getting
better all the time and so
you might have to be provide an example
of what a very heavy computational task
is and that may be uh calculating
a risk on an insurance application
against
many many variables that may be
something that is seen as
computationally very heavy but what you
can do in that example is you can
offload the task to another solution
that's designed for it and use apis to
pass the data back and forth
pro
javascript is used for building out your
applications with
node.js great lots of people know
javascript
a
restriction and again this is evolving
as javascript itself evolves is that
when you do a callback you may end up
doing lots of nested call backs
if you're doing something that's very
complicated again another way around the
con and so this is one of the things
that i always look for is if you have a
blocker or a barrier
how do you get around that barrier and
so for instance when you're talking uh
to your recruiter
you can say look the reason why i use
node.js is that it's fast it's events
driven i can use javascript there are
some challenges and but what i do to get
around those challenges are and that's
where you can say that you know you may
run the complex script off and you may
write that in net or java or php and
then use an api to do the response back
into node.js so you get the benefits of
both worlds but minimize the investment
in having to manage a complex
environment such as java versus a
relatively simple environment with
node.js
the node package manager makes it
extremely easy to access just an awful
lot of functionality with over 50 000
packages there's a package for that
so from being able to have a
tool that creates unique identifiers
that you might need to have for
generating content that gets posted into
a database through to being able to
connect to databases through you know to
running so many different solutions and
the npm package manager with this access
to so many different packages makes it
great
for um getting access to all that
content now khan is working with
relational databases with node.js isn't
as easy as a nosql database now you can
do it and there are ways around that and
what i would do when this question comes
up is always kind of pivot to say hey
this is how you can actually then
get around building out that application
pro for node.js designed for streaming
huge amounts of data in and out
a con is that node.js is single threaded
and so it can be cpu intensive
but again there are ways around that and
a good way around that is scaling your
solution in an elastic environment such
as the cloud
so what is the command used to import an
external library and so to import an
external library the command is the
required command and so an example we
have here is uh you can start a variable
and the variable is going to be for http
and you're going to then require the
http service and that means that the
application itself won't run unless the
external library the http library is
installed
okay so those were our introductory
questions for node.js let's kind of
pivot and take a look at the
intermediate questions that you would be
asked
so what does event-driven programming
mean
so event-driven programming means that
if something happens something else will
happen in response so for instance if
you click a mouse that mouse click is an
event that means something has to
respond to that event uh just think of
it as cause and effect it's just the
basic motion of physics so that's what
event driven programming means
you also look at it as a callback
function
so that when an element is executed
something will happen in response
so what is an event loop in node.js
so an event loop in node.js is when you
do an asynchronous call and
what that essentially means is that
you are sending out
data and then non-blocking input output
from node.js is pulling data back in
what is an event emitter in node.js so
an event emitter has really two areas of
focus one is that it manages the classes
that hold all the objects
within your event and we have an example
of this on the right hand side
and then whenever an event actually is
thrown
the functions are then called on that
event synchronously so for instance we
have in our example on the right hand
side we create an event and then we have
the functions and that executed in a
series from
that event
so let's talk about the api functions in
node.js so there's two types
one is an asynchronous non-blocking
function
and the second is a synchronous blocking
function and the difference between the
two of them is asynchronous is that
there is no structure to the order
for how the
api is resolved synchronous means that
when the feedback from the api is
received you have to execute
the response
in a series for how the response is sent
to you
so what is a package.json file so the
package.json file is at the heart of our
node.js package when we actually will
initialize a solution folder to be a
node.js
package
you'll find that the package itself
holds all of the metadata
that's particular to the project you're
working on such as project name version
requirements it is you have to have
installed in the root of the directory
for the project and again look at any of
the videos that we have on note.js we do
have demonstrations within those videos
that actually then go through and break
out um how to create that root package
and you'll see how you can actually then
go ahead and update the instructions or
the metadata within the package
so here we have an example of what that
metadata looks like so again this kind
of continues that question of what is a
package.json file and you may be asked
you know what is the metadata and why is
it important and the metadata is a
basic uh json collection of pairing of
key details such as name version
description and then the custom version
that you put so for instance under name
you could create a name for your project
there can't be any spaces uh what is the
version and description
and what is the main or starting path
for the solution typically that would be
index.js but it could be anything.js
but index.js is typical simply because
index.html is the starting point for a
typical web application
so how would you use a url module in
node.js
so with the url module what it allows
you to do is really two things one is
that it provides the resolution and
passing of a url
for utilities in your application
and then it allows you to
extend your module with built-in
solutions and split up the web address
into a readable format
so in this example
we have the url and the response it
would give
for that url which would then be a year
and month and it would be in a readable
format so they would read out as
2020 and then the month
so
what is express.js and you've heard me
mention this a couple of times in the
video we actually have a separate video
on express.js and express.js is a web
application framework that allows you to
build out web solutions
for both mobile and traditional desktop
right inside of node.js so it's very
easy to use
um being able to install web.js is as
simple as requiring express to be
installed in the example that we have
here on the screen it's a full solution
of showing how to actually build out a
solution with web.js
so in this example uh you start off the
first two lines uh require express to be
installed and the store comes from node
packet manager then we have a simple
application that will then send to the
browser window
a hello world message confirming that
express is up and running and then the
third block of content starting with
virus server actually will define the
port
where your application is going to run
so in this instance
the port is going to run on localhost
and the
port will be port 8081
and so you can actually go to localhost
colon8081
and when you do that that will trigger
the application that will forward up the
message hello world and it's all coming
from express.js
so what are streams in node.js so
streams are objects that allow you to
read and write data continuously back
and forth within your application and
there's really four different types of
streams there's readable writable duplex
and transform
the readable stream through which data
can be read
the writable streams that you can
actually write to
a duplex is a stream where it is both
readable and writeable
and
transform our streams that can be
manipulate the data
while it is being read or written
so how do you update and delete a
dependency so say for instance we want
to install uh something like express so
if you wanted to install express what
you would do is you would just write
them inside of your project you want to
go to terminal window and write in the
command npm install express
if you want to update the
dependencies within your node package
manager to update all of them all you
have to do is
write the command npm update all
dependencies
and then if you want to explicitly
uninstall a dependency such as
express.js
that's using the uninstall
command and so that would again be going
to terminal window and you would type
npm uninstall express
and again it's really easy to create a
simple server in node.js that will run a
simple command
the http service is actually built into
node.js you don't need to use express.js
i typically use express.js when i want
to do a web server because typically
what i find is that i will want to go
and do something more complicated but if
you want to do something that
illustrates just the core functionality
uh within node.js you can actually just
require the core http service that
actually comes as part of node.js and
then you can actually then go ahead and
tell it to create a service and then to
write in plain text
a command um or text string such as in
this case it'll be hello world and that
would pop out and then the final line is
to then uh listen that if you go to a
web browser that's on port
127.0.01 or localhost
and go to
port colon 8080 once you actually go to
that that will trigger this application
and you'll get the text hello world pop
up on your screen
so explain synchronous and non-blocking
apis in node.js
so all the apis
in node.js are asynchronous which means
that they are non-blocking which means
you can run them continuously um and
scale around that which is just
fantastic it's one of the reasons why
node.js can scale so fast and the eighth
means that the apis can return data send
data after it's been called and really
increase the efficiency of events as
they are triggered within node.js
so how do you implement async and
node.js and so the example that we have
on the left hand side allows us to
trigger async and it's using the async
function and as you can see in this
example uh it's actually something that
can be done very quickly in this example
we're actually
making a command to logo host and app
that's running on port 3000 and then
depending on
what we get if there's an error message
and then we'll have error message go to
the console log which is the terminal
window and if
we get a response to an application
then we'll actually get a positive
response which would be fetched response
so
again very quickly and easy that you use
the async function
to be able to build out and you to get
your asynchronous code
so what is the purpose of module exports
so
a module export is a way to encapsulate
your the entire code for a solution in a
single package in a single file and then
you can then
share that with other developers so
you're all working from the same
environment
so what is a callback function in
node.js a callback function is
essentially that once you run and you've
triggered an event and the response has
been given
you want to be able to then have a
callback to validate that the task is
complete
all right let's move on to the final set
of questions which is advanced node.js
questions
so what is reppl in node.js so repl
stands for read eval print and loop and
this is a reference to the
unix and linux background that node.js
has
so rapple will perform the following
tasks the read will be actually
passing the javascript you'll read that
and store it in memory eval
takes and evaluates the data structure
print will then print the results often
on the console window or onto a web page
and then loop
loops the above command until the user
presses control c twice
what is the control flow function so the
control flow function is a piece of code
that runs between several of the
asynchronous functions and that's it it
actually controls
how those functions execute
so how control flow controls the
function calls and it does it through
four ways one is it controls the order
of execution
it collects the data it limits the
concurrency and then it also calls the
next step in a program again this is a
management tool for how your functions
are called within node.js
so what is the difference between fork
and spawn methods in node.js
so the essential difference between the
two of them is that if you use the fork
method it will actually trigger and
create a new instance of the v8 engine
the engine running nodejs and will then
run the application in that new instance
with spawn
it's somewhat similar it doesn't
actually generate a new v8 instance so
it's actually creating a new process but
it's within the same v8 instance as the
previous application that it was spawned
from
explain to me what is the use of buffer
class in node.js
so with the buffer class what you're
looking at doing is you're actually
controlling the raw data of a set of
arrays and integers
and the memory allocation outside of the
v8 heap buffer class is used because
pure javascript is not compatible with
binary data
what is piping in node.js
so
piping is the ability to connect the
output of one stream to another stream
that could be a data stream it could be
any stream that you're working with
but it does normally get used to pass
data from one stream to another
so what are some of the flags used in
the rewrite operation files
so r dash is used for read w's for
opening a file for writing
a dash is opening a file for appending
so the collection that you have here you
don't have to really memorize all of
them but to have a few of them
in the back of your mind is always a
good
reference point
so how would you open a file using
node.js
so
the syntax you would use would be
the
fs.open and that would then open up a
file
explain to me what callback hell is
so callback hell also known as the
pyramid of doom is when you have too
many
nested unreadable and unmanageable
callbacks intensively cycle within each
other and they're constantly reading to
each other and they're not able to
resolve the solution
and uh this is a you know it's a big
problem and this is what why it's called
callback hell because you're not able to
finalize the the app you're working on
what is a reactive pattern in node.js
and so a reactor pattern is a concept of
non-blocking i o operations
can you explain to me the test pyramid
for node.js so the test pyramid and this
is standard for testing uh for all
devops is really split into three key
areas you have unit tests integration
tests and then end to end or e2e tests
the unit tests are tests that you're
actually doing your raw code
that you're working on and the goal
there is to be able to validate that the
code you're writing is consistently
working
integration allows you to
have tests that integrate your raw code
that you're working with in your
application with other areas of an
application and then end to end is the
whole system the whole interface as it
were for your solution
describe the exit codes of node.js
so annexa code is a specific code that
identifies the end of a specific process
and examples of exit codes are unused
uncaught fatal exception
fatal error
internal javascript evaluation area
these are all good examples of exit
codes
so what is a middleware can you explain
the concept of middleware in node.js
so
with middleware it is the ability to be
able to connect to a system and get data
from it
that's outside of node.js so
this may be executing a type of code or
updating and modifying a request in
response to a specific type of object uh
finishing the request response cycle
can you explain to me what are the types
of http requests that you may use when
working with node.js
there are actually quite a lot but four
of them that you might use would be get
post
head and delete
and these are if you've done any web
application before particularly worked
with forms inside of a web application
you're probably very familiar certainly
with get and post
again it's the request to retrieve data
post is generally used for changing
stating and data
head is similar to get but also ask for
a response if there's no body content so
if you're using if you're developing an
api this would be a good one to use and
delete is used to delete the
predetermined source
so how would you connect to mongodb
database and with node.js and you use
that using the [ __ ] client and the
example we have on the left hand side
illustrates that
what is the use of node underscore emv
and so the node underscore emv is an
environment variable that stands for
node environment in express server so
the example we have on the right hand
side allows you to illustrate how you
would do that for say a production
environment
so what are some of the various timing
features in node.js so
the timing functions that you could use
here set timeout and then clear timeout
and you to schedule code execution that
you'd have inside of your application
you also have set interval and clear
interval to execute a block of code up
multiple times in your application
uh set intermediate and clear
intermediate to
execute code and that is at the end of
your application
and with that we have come to an end of
this video on node.js full course i hope
it was informative and interesting if
you have any questions about the topics
covered in this video please ask anyway
in the comment section below our team
will help you solve your queries thanks
for watching stay safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you